[Musique]
Fabrice Fille, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. On vous reçoit dans le
cadre de votre activité qui est le
journalisme, le journalisme
d'investigation. Vous travaillez chez
Méiapart.
Je vois un petit signe de tête. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Bah oui, Fabrice Arfi.
Euh je suis journaliste depuis 1999,
c'est-à-dire depuis l'âge de 18 ans. Je
viens de Lyon où j'ai commencé euh à la
fois dans la presse euh locale, à la
fois dans la presse nationale, à la fois
dans la presse payante, à la fois dans
la presse gratuite, à la fois dans la
presse féminine, dans la presse
d'annonce légale. et je suis à Mediapart
depuis sa fondation en 2008 et où je
dirige aujourd'hui le service dit des
enquêtes avec une deuxième personne qui
s'appelle Michael Hdenberg.
On vous reçoit on va commencer la
première partie de l'interview sur
Sarkozy Kaddafi.
Ouais.
Petit sujet que vous pouvez nous résumer
et on va vous poser des questions pour
rentrer dans le détail.
Ouais.
Est-ce que Sarkozy est un menteur ? Ah
oui, SarkoZ euh euh
est un est un menteur euh indéiablement
à la à la lumière de de ce dossier euh
et notamment depuis qu'il a été mis en
examen pour euh et euh
la présomption de l'innocence, non ? Ah
non, ben bien sûr la présomption
d'innocence toujours la présomption de
l'innocence c'est à force urie quand on
est mise en examen. C'est que la mise en
examen d'un point de vue judiciaire
c'est à la fois la con la concrétisation
pardon d'indice grave et concordant qui
permett de penser que quelqu'un a
participé à la commission de fait. C'est
la nature de la mise en examen. Mais
parce qu'il est mise en examen, il est
présumé innocent d'un point de vue
judiciaire et on est euh considéré
coupable d'un point de vue judiciaire
jusqu'à ce qu'on a été seulement quand
on a été condamné et reconnu comme tel
par un par un tribunal. Première
instance appelle et puis après il y a
cassation la cassation. Mais il y a il y
a un leur je trouve français à à vouloir
agiter toujours la présomption
d'innocence qui est une notion juridique
qui est une notion juridique capital
mais pour empêcher comme si on mettait
un bandeau sur les yeux du public pour
les empêcher et empêcher les citoyens de
regarder les faits tels qu'ils sont. Euh
nous journalistes, on est là pour
documenter le réel tel qu'il est, mettre
sur la table des informations d'intérêt
public, vérifier qui alimentent la
conversation. Il y en a qui sont pour,
il y en a qui sont contre, il y en a qui
sont ni pour ni contre, bien au
contraire, peu importe. Euh les faits
sont les faits. Nous, on n'est pas là
pour qualifier pénalement les faits. Ça
c'est le boulot des juges. Et dans le
dossier libien, depuis qu'il a été mis
en examen, et c'est ce que je disais,
c'est unique hein dans l'histoire de la
République d'un point de vue judiciaire
que une institution, l'institution
judiciaire accuse un ancien président de
la République d'avoir été stipendié par
une dictature à laquelle on fera par
ailleurs la guerre quelques années plus
tard. Puisque
les Diamants de Bokasa non, il a pas été
mis. les les diamants de Bokassa, par
exemple, il y a jamais eu de procédure
judiciaire d'ouverte, il y a jamais eu
de mise en examen d'un président de la
République en France, même pas à
l'histoire de la 5e République, pour des
faits de d'avoir été corrompu par une
puissance étrangère, hein. C'est on
parle beaucoup de l'affaire russe et de
l'ingérence russe
aux États-Unis qui fait l'objet du des
investigations du procureur spécial
Müller.
de mon point de vue l'affaire de
l'ingérence russe x 10 hein puisque là
on parle de financement direct à la fois
politique he de l'argent politique
partie de plusieurs poches au en Libye
plusieurs dignitaires arrivé dans
plusieurs entre plusieurs mains
différentes en France mais aussi de
l'argent personnel confère l'achat de
l'appartement de de Claude Guéan en mars
2008 dont aujourd'hui on a pu démontrer
que la Libye était liée à l'achat de de
de cet appartement et il y a seulement 3
ans plus tard, une guerre qui est
déclenchée par la France qui fait
semblant de découvrir que Kaddafi était
un tyran. parce qu'il était he toujours
été un tyran Kaddafi, il y a pas de
doute là-dessus mais c'est SarkoZi et
c'est la France de SarkoZi qui a vendu
du matériel d'espionnage numérique.
Vous parle de vous parlez d'Aesis,
je parle de l'affaire Amesis Eagle et le
logiciel Eagle et I2 à l'époque comme ça
s'appelait Amesis, c'est la France qui a
vendu des armes la France de SarkoZi
notamment des missiles antichar
fabriqués par une filiale de ADS qui
s'appelle MBDA. C'est la France, celle
de Sarkozy, qui a tout fait pour faire
sauter le mandat d'arrêt du beau-frère
de Kaddafi qui était aussi le chefi.
Ah voilà, Abdallah Senusi qui était le
chef du renseignement militaire qui
était le principal condamné en France
dans l'affaire du décès 100 UTA qui
était un attentat. On a fait péter un
avion de ligne en 89 au-dessus du du
désert du du Ténéré. Il y a eu plus de
170 morts, 54 français. Bien, la bande à
Sarkozy a tout fait pour faire sauter le
mandat d'arrêt de de de Susi. C'est la
France de Sarkozy qui, comme aucune
autre démocratie à ce moment-là, a
accueilli le dictateur Mohamar Kaddafi,
on s'en souvient tous, en décembre 2007
à Paris, la tente bédouine dans les
jardins de la République, le château de
Versailles privatisé, le Louvre, les 6
jours de visite d'État. Aucun pays n'a
autant notabilisé ce qui était quelques
années plus tôt la la l'État paria,
l'état terroriste et seulement 3 ans
après, on fait semblant de découvrir que
c'est un dictateur. Alors, il s'agit pas
de dire que la la guerre est une
fabrication, hein. C'est pas du tout
notre propos. Ça l'a jamais été. Euh il
y a évidemment eu des révoltes euh d'un
peuple notamment celui de Bengazi qui
était dans les mâchoires du dictateur.
Euh mais les arguments qui ont été
avancés pour entrer en guerre à savoir
qu'il y avait des massacres massifs de
population civile, voir comme ça a été
dit à un moment donné à la tribune de
l'ONU qu'il y avait un génocide en
cours, cela est faux. Il y avait une
début de guerre civile, il y avait une
répression, il y a pas de doute de
stimulé stimulé ou pas les poches
insurrectionnelles ? Ah, je je je moi je
ne réponds que de ce que j'écrit et j'ai
pas d'élément pour pouvoir dire que ça a
été stimulé. Je
Vous avez enquêté dessus ou pas ?
Oui oui mais je je Oui oui, on on a
enquêté dessus
sur la stimulation des révoltes ou pas ?
Non alors sur les stimulations des
révoltes, je n'ai pas d'éléments. Voilà,
je n'ai je n'ai pas d'élément qui me
permett de soutenir quoi que ce soit et
de de ce qu'on sait euh les dissidents
libiens, les rebelles libiens, le peuple
libyen avait de bonnes raisons de
vouloir s'émanciper des mâchoires du
dictateur. Il y a pas il y a pas de
doute là-dessus. C'était une dictature
et c'est d'ailleurs la folie de la
situation. C'est c'est quand même grâce
au au logiciel Eagle d'Aisis que les
services de sécurité libiens, un
logiciel vendu par la France de SarkoZi,
contrat sur lequel l'émissaire préféré
de SarkoZi, alors aujourd'hui il fait
comme s'il l'a jamais connu mais
Takedine main dans la main quand même
avec SarkoZi et ses amis à toucher de
l'argent. C'est grâce à ce logiciel là
qu'on a pu surveiller, attraper,
torturer des opposants de Bengazi en
2011 au au début de la guerre. Bon et
depuis sa mise en examen, c'est vrai
pour répondre à la question que Sarkozy
s'est enferré, englué dans des mensonges
répétés, ce qu'on appelle parfois un peu
facilement des fake news aujourd'hui
pour essayer de se défendre de de des
accusations qui le visent.
Il va aller en tôle ou pas ?
Non, ça je sais pas s'il va aller s'il
va aller en prison. Euh pour l'instant,
on est dans une procédure judiciaire qui
qui a connu une accélération euh
spectaculaire, hein, et c'est pas fini,
mais qui a connu déjà une accélération
spectaculaire en mars dernier avec euh
euh la la garde à vue. C'était 26h de
garde à vue de de Nicolas Sarkoi. Donc,
il
ce n'est pas vraiment une garde à vue.
Si. Alors oui, il y a un débat sur le
fait que en effet il n'a pas dormi sur
place et qui c'est c'est une faveur qui
lui a été fait faite pardon par par les
enquêteurs précisément je crois pour
pour ne pas avoir à rentrer dans une
polémique de la justice spectacle
du président qu'on qu'on traiterait avec
des sentiments de reespierriste et de
justice rouge ou je ne sais quoi qui est
quand même l'argument qui est
perpétuellement avancé.
par les présumés délinquants en col
blanc dans ce type de dossier. Il est
mise en examen pour des faits qui si ça
devait amener à une condamnation
judiciaire son passible de de prison
ferme. Mais en France, il y a un tabou
français. C'est une question et un débat
délicat hein, c'est un débat compliqué
mais il y a un tabou français sur
l'incarcération de ce qu'on appelle les
délinquants en col blanc.
Les VIP les VIP euh tout big tout jail.
tout big tout big tout gel. Le secret
défense, vous avez vu euh depuis
quelques années, ça a changé. Il est
passé de 100 à 150 ans ou quelque chose
comme ça, normal, pas normal. Et
comment ça il est passé à 150 ?
On a augmenté le le temps de du secret
défense.
Ah, le la durée du secret défense. Oui.
Alors, en fait, le le
comment dire
euh moi j'ai toujours considéré qu'il
fallait du secret en démocratie. Voilà,
il faut évidemment du secret, il faut il
faut du secret médical, il faut du il
faut du secret de la vie privée,
il faut du secret des affaires.
Ouais, pourquoi pas ? Pourquoi pas que
euh pour lutter contre l'espionnage
économique, entreprise entre elles,
pourquoi pas ? Il faut du secret
défense.
Le problème et c'est un comme on dit
dans l'armée un rétex quoi, un retour
d'expérience du travail qui est le mien
qui est simplement d'être reporter et
journaliste. C'est que en France le
secret il a deux tards. La théorie du
secret, la théorie gouvernementale
autour de secret est lestée par deux
fardeaux. Le premier c'est qu'il est mal
défini où ça commence un secret où ça
s'arrête et il est mal contrôlé.
conséquence euh on voit beaucoup de de
pouvoirs exécutifs
utiliser et agiter le secret pour
protéger des intérêts qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'objet que le secret est
censé protéger. C'est comme ça qu'on a
vu dans des affaires de corruption le
secret défense être agité pour empêcher
de découvrir des faits qui ont à voir
avec le porte-monnaie et les poches
politiques voire personnelles de
certains responsables et rien avec la
défense des intérêts supérieurs de la
nation. Mais ça peut être aussi vrai
pour le secret médical. La maladie de
François Mitteran, le cancer de François
Mitteran qui
Pompidou
ou la maladie de Pompidou en 73.
Si je reprends le cancer de de Miteran
qui est sauf erreur de ma part
diagnostiqué en octobre 80 donc dès
qu'il devient président 88 il est déjà
très affaibli dans un régime ultra
présidentialiste, c'està-dire qui
personnalise hein le le pouvoir. On
rappelle quand même que par exemple en
France
aller à la guerre, faire la guerre,
déclencher une guerre, c'est la
responsabilité d'un homme. Le Parlement
ne se prononce pas sur le déclenchement
de la guerre. C'est quand même pas rien.
On va larguer des bombes sur des pays
bleux, blanc, rouge au nom des citoyens
français. Le Parlement qui est la
représentation n'a pas son mot à dire.
Il a son mot à dire sur la reconduction
de la guerre mais pas sur le pas sur le
déclenchement. Par exemple, ce qui s'est
passé dans la guerre en Libye. Bon euh
je pourrais parler du pouvoir nucléaire,
de tous les pouvoirs ultra concentrés
qu'il y a entre les mains du président
de la République en France. Et bien
qu'un homme confère François Mitteran
puisse être frappé d'une maladie qui
pourrait interférer dans sa charge
publique, je suis désolé, c'est une
information d'intérêt public. C'est une
information qui t'a choqué, qui de mon
point de vue est beaucoup plus d'intérêt
public que Mazarine. Mazarine
Pinjot,
hein ? Arine Pinjot dont il y avait eu
un scandale sur on a utilisé des moyens
de l'État pour protéger cet enfant
caché. Sincèrement hein, je j'essaie de
jouer franc jeu là. Si j'avais été
journaliste à l'époque et j'avais eu les
informations, je suis pas certain que je
les aurais rendu publique. Parce que au
fond, si on réfléchit sur Mazarine,
c'est quoi le problème ? c'est que ce
soit un enfant adultérain.
Moi ça me choque pas qu'on que les
moyens de l'État protègent des enfants
du président. Ce sont des cibles les
enfants du président
et on peut faire chanter le président.
On peut prendre en otage les enfants du
président. C'est normal de les protéger.
Donc ça ne me choque pas qu'on protège
une fille du président, même si c'est
une fille cachée. Considérer que ce soit
un scandale, ce serait considéré que
c'est un scandale parce que c'est une
fille adultérine. Donc je je je dis pas
que j'aurais pas publié, je ne sais pas,
jeis pas dans le contexte de l'époque,
mais je dis que c'est de mon point de
vue beaucoup moins d'intérêt public vu
de loin et d'où je suis. Donc c'est
facile de dire ça avec le recul hein,
que la maladie du président. Et
pourtant, la santé, le secret médical
est un secret qu'il faut évidemment
protéger. Quoi de plus intime avec les
sentiments, la vie amoureuse que la
maladie ? Mais agissons au cas par cas
et à la jurisprudence.
Revenons revenons à la à la mythomanie
présidentielle, la mythomanie supposée
présidentielle.
Euh on a suivi le cache investigation
d'hier d'Élise Luis. On lui passe le
bonjour d'ailleurs.
Euh, il y a eu quelques petits décès
suspects.
Hm.
À votre avis, euh qui est derrière ça ?
Euh
disons qu'il y a indéiablement un parfum
de mort qui entoure le dossier d' bien
et de danger forcément
et de danger
surtout pour ceux qui savent c'està-dire
les témoins ou les acteurs directs du
dossier. Il y a des exemples documentés
précis de de de ce que je vais dire. Par
exemple,
on a un ancien premier ministre et
ministre du pétrole libien qui s'appelle
Chou Ganem. Bon euh qui est au cœur de
l'affaire des financements qui est
vraiment les mains dans le camboui du
financement
présumé oculte de la campagne et pas que
de de la France et et de la SarkoZi
entre 2005 et et 2007
de l'UMP
de à l'époque c'était c'était l'UMP mais
pas que he il y a aussi eu beaucoup de
financement personnel d'enrichissement
personnel dans ce dossier. Cet homme,
il est l'auteur de carnet manuscrit. vo
il consignait dans un carnet manuscrit
ses mémoires parce qu'il voulait écrire
d'ailleurs son autobiographique. Euh et
euh à la date d'avril 2007, il a
consigné une partie des versements qui
ont été opérés pour euh la campagne de
Nicolas Sarkozy par la dictature
libyenne. Ces documents, ils ont été
retrouvés par la justice
autrichienne. D'abord la police
autrichienne ont été transmis à la
justice norvégienne dans le cadre d'un
dossier précis et puis transmis à la
justice française. ont été authentifiés
par ces trois pays européens et
authentifiés comme datant de 2007 et
c'est un élément majeur de l'affaire
libyenne moins pour ce qu'il décrit les
versements qui ont été corroborés et
documentés
de manière extérieure à ces carnet mais
parce que étant de 2007 ça vient
fracasser la version de Sarkozy dans ce
dossier. La version de SarkoZi dans ce
dossier, c'est dire l'affaire libienne,
c'est une machination, c'est un complot
qui a été créé à l'aube de la guerre par
un régime aux abois, le régime Kaddafi.
Bon en 2007, Shukriganem, il pouvait pas
prévoir 4 ans à l'avance la guerre en
Libye. En 2007, c'était la lune de miel
entre Sarkozi et Kaddafi. On en a parlé
la visite notamment de de décembre. Donc
il pouvait pas prévoir 4 ans à l'avance,
c'est pas possible. Donc c'est la preuve
matérielle que ce que dit Sarkozy sur la
soi-disant machination liée à l'affaire
des financements est fausse. Bon et ben
cet homme euh moins de 24 heures après
des révélations de Média Part, c'était
en avril 2012, il a été retrouvé au
petit matin flottant dans le Danube à
Vienne en Autriche où il avait trouvé
refuge
pendant la guerre. Bon euh aujourd'hui
cette mort est considérée, je cite,
ouvrez les guillemets, comme hautement
suspecte notamment par les services de
renseignement américain et notamment par
euh euh un ancien conseiller de
d'Hillary Clinton qui un jour lui avait
écrit un mail en parlant de cette mort
dont l'objet était euh "Si tu aimes les
crimes non résolus, lis cette histoire".
Voilà. Bon, mort suspecte. Bon, il y en
a une autre. Il y a un homme, le cache
investigation de de Nicolas Veskovashi
et Lu en parlait hier, non pas de cet
homme mais de l'objet qu'il a convoyé, à
savoir des enregistrements clandestins.
Le régime Kaddafi était connu pour
enregistrer clandestinement euh ses
visiteurs. C'est pas le seul dictateur à
faire ça. Omar Bongo était réputé pour
ça. Et donc il y a toute une course
poursuite sur où sont les bandes hein,
les bandes et est-ce qu'on entendrait
dans ces bandes les négociations qu'il a
pu avoir entre les les Français et les
libiens avant la présidentielle de 2007
? Bien, il y a un homme qui s'appelle
Mohamed Albishari qui était le fils d'un
ministre de Kaddafi qui a été mort dans
un accident de voiture d'ailleurs dont
on a découvert après que c'était un
attentat du régime contre l'un de ses
propres ministres. Et cet homme, Mohamed
Albishari était un antiadapfiste
acharné, hein. Bon, pendant la guerre,
il et et juste après la guerre, grâce
aux rebelles notamment de Bengazi qu'il
connaissait très bien et de Misrata, il
a pu récupérer un certain nombre
d'enregistrements, des fameux
enregistrements, des cassettes du régime
libyen. Par l'entremise d'un
neurodéputé, d'un ancien neurodéputé
français,
comment il s'appelle ? Michel Scarbonki
qui est un cousin de Bernard Scorini,
l'ancien chef des services de
renseignement de Sarkozy,
le Squal
le dit le Squal.
Cet homme a été présenté au service de
renseignement français à la fois à la
DGSE, à la fois à la DCIRI qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la DGSI qui était dirigée
par Squarini. Ce que je dis là est
documenté au dossier judiciaire he je le
sors pas de mon chapeau. Bon et il a
présenté un extrait des enregistrements.
On sait pas ce qu'il y a sur les bandes.
On sait pas. On sait pas. On sait que
c'est avec des Français mais on sait pas
qui parle et on sait pas de quoi. Ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on sait c'est que la
bande a été authentifiée. Même ce qu'
par qui ?
Par les services de renseignement
français. Bon et donc on avait on sait
que les fameux enregistrements
clandestins, ils existent hein, ils ont
existé. Bon euh où ils sont maintenant ?
Quand le fameux Mohamed Al Bishari
devait revenir en France, il habitait en
Tunisie pour avancer dans les
négociations et la remise des cartons,
paraît-il, il y en avait 70 avec les
bandes euh sur le chemin de l'aéroport
en quittant sa maison à Tunis, il est
mort. Il est mort d'une crise de de du
diabète. Alors, il a 38 ans, il avait 38
ans, il était diabétique. Bon, comme
tous les diabétiques, il savaient se
soigner, il était il faisait attention.
Il est mort d'une crise de diabète.
Euh il y a eu très peu de diligence
autour de sa mort. Voilà une autre mort.
Je peux donner un troisème exemple, je
veux pas être trop long, mais il y a il
y a un homme clé du dossier qui est
l'ancien directeur de cabinet de de de
Moimar Kaddafi qu'on voit d'ailleurs
dans le dans le cachet investigation qui
s'appelle Béchir Salé. un peu le
l'argentier du régime, l'homme de de
tous les secrets. Bon, euh cet homme euh
doit sa survie euh au sens propre du
terme euh et au sens judiciaire du terme
à deux reprises à Nicolas Sarkozy
personnellement. D'abord pendant la
guerre en Libye alors qu'il est arrêté
par le CNT qui était le gouvernement
transitoire libien, les antisadfistes
qui étaient en fait composé pour partie
de cadfiste, pour partie de de
d'authentique démocrates et pour partie
d'islamistes l'avait appréhendé, l'avait
arrêté en 2011 et à la demande de la
France, il a été relâché. C'est un homme
qui alors lui est totalement au cœur des
financements libiens et c'est la DGSE
qui l'a exfiltré de Tripoli pour
l'amener en Tunisie puis en France. Ça
aussi c'est documenté par des notes de
la DGSE qu'on a rendu public à la fois
dans Media Part et dans le livre qu'on a
fait avec Carlasquier sur sur l'affaire
sur l'affaire libyenne
qui s'appelle comment ?
Avec les compliments du guide. VO qui
était un bouquin qui est sorti en
octobre dernier chez chez Fayard. Bon
cet homme est protégé ensuite en France.
Il est territorialement en France alors
qu'il est recherché par un mandat
d'arrêt Interpol. Il a une notice rouge
comme contre lui et il est protégé par
la France de Nicolas Sarkozy. On est en
20112. En 2012, on fait cette fameuse
révélation. On publie un document issu
des archives libiennes. Sarkozy dira que
c'est un faux. La justice dira pas du
tout à deux reprises, ça n'est pas du
tout un faux. Bon euh 5 jours après la
révélation de ce document qui a été
destiné hein à à Bécher Sally, il était
le destinataire de de cette note qui
était une promesse de financement datant
de décembre 2006 pour la campagne de de
Sarkozy par les par les Libyens. euh
panique au sommet de l'État parce qu'on
découvre que la France en fait a sur son
sol un libyen recherché par Interpol et
le gouvernement qu'on a installé et en
fait on le protège au lieu de le
remettre aux autorités euh compétentes.
Le même Bernard Squarzini, c'est un
digne d'un film d'espionnage avec un un
intermédiaire qui s'appelle Alexandre
Jori organise alors c'est une scène de
genre incroyable de polar organise ça se
passe d'abord au pied de la tour effel
il y a des rendez-vous confidentiels au
pied de la tour Effel et organise la
fuite de Bcher Salé de France c'estàd
que les autorités françaises au lieu de
l'arrêter et de le présenter Interpol et
puis de le déférer devant les libiens,
ils font le contraire. ils organisent sa
sa cavale et et là il y a des euh il y a
des éléments de de cette période
2011-212 qui montrent que Becher Salé
dit qu'il sera redevable à vie à Nicolas
Sarkozy de ce qu'il a fait. Aujourd'hui,
le dossier judiciaire ouvre même une
piste incroyable, c'est que Bechir Salé
en fait est parti avec l'essentiel des
documents sur le financement libyen de
la France en 2007 et que c'était même sa
monnaie d'échange pendant la guerre pour
être sauvé de de la sorte. Ça aussi
c'est au dossier judiciaire. Bon, cet
homme pendant des années a et on
comprend pourquoi, vu la fidélité, la
loyauté qu'il a vis-à-vis de l'homme qui
l'a sauvé, a toujours catégoriquement
démenti
l'affaire libyenne. Bon, mais le temps a
fait son œuvre. Je suis pas dans sa
tête, je sais pas ce qui s'est passé et
il a commencé à un peu amender ses
démentis d'autant qu'il est complètement
fait par l'enquête judiciaire. C'est
l'homme qui est derrière les
financements de Claude Guillant et
l'achat de son appartement en 2008 entre
autres. Bon, c'était le directeur de
cabinet de Kaddafis et c'était
l'opérateur de de de tout ça. Bon et
bien cet homme en février dernier, il a
été victime d'une tentative d'assassinat
en Afrique du Sud où il est où il est
réfugié.
Il a pris une balle,
il a pris deux balles. Il a survécu
miraculeusement. C'est un miracle. C'est
lui qui était visé. Son chauffeur a pas
été visé. Manifestement, la voiture n'a
pas été visitée. Donc ça ne ressemble en
rien à un crime crapuleux. On a même
nous interrogé sa famille hein qu'on a
retrouvé dans Media part et son frère
dit c'est lié à l'affaire libienne. Bon
c'est pas parce que ils le disent que
c'est vrai mais en tout cas c'est
intéressant de savoir que les plus
proches de Béchir Salé imputent cette
tentative d'assassinat à ses volontés de
commencer à parler parce qu'il
commençait à vouloir parler à la
J'ouvre une parenthèse il y a pas eu
d'analyse balistique. On sait quel
calibre on sait
alors moi je ne connais pas le dossier
criminel sud-africain. l'adorerai. Je le
connais pas donc je peux pas je peux pas
répondre à cette question mais voilà
troisème personne al lui n'est pas mort
mais que la mort a frôé dans cette
affaire et puis il y a un autre qui est
le premier des Kaddafis quand même
Mohamar Kaddafi. La mort de Kaddafi
demeure aujourd'hui un mystère
qui a tiré
et ben on sait pas. Voilà Kaddafi
d'abord d'abord renverser le régime hein
et tuer le tyrant. C'était pas dans le
mandat de l'ONU déjà de base comme
dirait mon fils. C'était pas dans le
mandat de l'ONU. Le mandat de l'ONU,
c'était une no fly zone, hein. Bon euh
dès les premières heures voir les
premiers jours de de la guerre, en fait
on a violé la résolution de de l'ONU.
Bon on sait que en octobre 2011 Kaddafi
s'était réfugié à Sirt qui était sa sa
ville natale d'ailleurs et puis il
s'enfuit. C'est un convoi d'une dizaine
de 44
avec des 44 français équipés par notre
technologie. Alors là, il y avait
c'était pas le en effet parce que Amesis
avait aussi vendu un 44 équipé à
Kaddafi. Manifestement, c'était pas
celui-là qui qui l'avait quand il s'est
quand il s'est quand il s'est enfui. On
sait que c'est un drone américain qui a
d'abord dronné le convoi pour le
disloquer hein. Il y avait entre 45 et
70 selon les sources 44 dans le dans le
convoi. Puis c'est un avion français.
C'est la dernière bombe de la guerre.
C'est un avion français qui a tiré pour
tuer. Voilà. Bon, miraculeusement là,
lui aussi il en réchappe et on a on a
tous vu les images de Kaddafi euh euh
chopé par la foule euh euh lyché par la
foule. Il était extrait comme ça d'un
d'un conduit euh d'égût. Euh il était
euh plus que sévèrement molesté. Il est
mis vivant sur une sur une sur une
voiture. Vous
vous rappelez de ces dernières paroles ?
Non. C'était quoi ces dernières paroles
?
Qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ? Qu'est-ce que
je t'ai fait moi ?
Qu'est-ce que Qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
moi ? Voyez, il y avait aussi un
paraît-il un tout ça pour ça qui un côté
très shakespearien dans dans voilà. Et
là, on a plus d'imag et on a le cadavre
de Kaddafi, on voit l'impact de balle.
Bon, l'ONU a demandé à pouvoir faire une
autopsie et avoir accès s'il en avait eu
aux autopsies du cadavre de Kaddafi. Le
CNT, donc le gouvernement trisard liben
qui était vraiment dans la main de la
France et du Qatar à l'époque, a refusé.
Donc on n pas de vérité médicale
scientifique sur la mort de Kaddafi. Ce
qu'on sait en revanche notamment grâce
aux révélations pas que mais du canard
enchaîné de son ancien rédacteur en chef
Claude Angéliie, c'est qu'il y avait une
cinquantaine d'hommes des forces
spéciales françaises sur place autour de
la scène qu'on qu'on décrit. Alors moi
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé. Je sais
pas qui a tiré. Ça peut très bien être
un libyen qui vivant
sous le jou de la dictature
se venge comme comme ça peut arriver
dans ce type de scène. Ça peut être
un des participants à la coalition, un
agent, une barbouse, j'en sais rien. Ce
qui est certain, ce qu'on peut dire de
manière factuelle, c'est que rien n'a
été fait pour le garder vivant. On le
chope, il est vivant. Rien n'a été fait
alors que si on avait des forces
militaires sur place, il était il y a
quand même un mandat d'arrêt de la CPI
he de la Cour pénale internationale
contre lui. On aurait pu le prendre
vivant, l'exfiltré puis l'amener à la
pour qu'il soit jugé. Bon bah le
résultat est le même. Qui qui est tiré
contre lui sur lui c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il peut plus témoigner lui non plus.
Est-ce que le fait que Sarkozy aille
faire des petites conférences au Qatar à
Doua, c'est un petit retour de service ?
Pas du tout. Je sais pas mais en tout
cas je sais pas c'est un retour de
service mais en tout cas ça montre le le
le
ça montre ça montre l'étonnante porosité
qui peut y avoir immédiatement. C'est
même plus du pantouflage quoi. C'est une
espèce de de fusion acquisition entre un
milieu qui est celui normalement de la
sphère publique et de l'intérêt public
avec des milieux financiers
qui sont pas réputés pour leur
philanthropie
et la sphère la sphère de l'argent
privé. Et et donc évidemment ça peut que
questionner comment un homme qui a été
le premier magistrat de France, le
garant des libertés, le garant en partie
de la Constitution et cetera et cetera à
la tête de l'État français se retrouve à
faire des conférences. On avait diffusé
nous une fois le on avait récupéré
l'enregistrement d'une des conférences
de 45 minutes. Je crois que c'est à peu
près 100000 € he les 45 minutes pour
pour Sarkozy. Sauf son respect, c'est
indigent. C'est c'est indigent ce qui
était raconté. Bon voilà. Bon bah s'il y
a des gens qui ont envie de payer 100000
€ pour ça, pourquoi pas ? Mais c'est
vrai que ça mériterait de voir et de
creuser un peu quels étaient les lien
avec qui payer pendant qu'il était
président. Voilà. Parce que le le le
financement c'est pas qu'après enfin
c'est pas qu'avant que il y ait des
faveurs et des contreparties, ça peut
être après s de rétro financement.
Est-ce que Claude Guanton est un crétin
? Non, je crois pas que L Claude Gué est
unétin et je crois même que c'est tout
sauf un crétin. En revanche, je crois
que c'est un homme euh
dont la loyauté euh confine euh pour
certains de ses proches à la folie
aujourd'hui.
Alors, quand je dis crétin, c'est
utiliser moins de 800 € en temps
d'années. Euh,
il faut il faut être un peu bête, il
faut être quoi ? Non non, il faut être
gonflé mégaloman.
Non, il faut être gonflé
d'un sentiment d'impunité dont nous qui
sommes n'évoluons pas dans ce type de
milieu avons du mal à à saisir
l'ampleur.
C'est la maladie du pouvoir.
Ouais, c'est la maladie du pouvoir
français.
Je peux même dire que moi dans toutes
les enquêtes que j'ai que j'ai que j'ai
que j'ai faites, j'y ai trouvé deux
invariants tout le temps, tout le temps,
tout le temps. C'est les paradis
fiscaux, espèce de boîte noire comme ça
au cœur de de de la mondialisation qui
permettent pas simplement de d'éviter de
payer l'impôt. Ça c'est une des
fonctions des paradis fiscaux, mais
c'est surtout des lieux qui permettent
de dissimuler l'origine et la
destination de l'argent sale. l'argent
du crime, l'argent de la drogue,
l'argent de la corruption, parfois
l'argent du terrorisme. Bon et le
deuxième invariant, c'est le sentiment
d'impunité. En fait, on on ne mesure pas
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
policiers anticorruption,
même si c'est des années après, ça peut
paraître surprenant vu de l'extérieur,
mais vont perquisitionner des années
après des gens sur des faits subodorés
qui auraient été commis par exemple 10
ans avant. On dit "Mais quand même 10
ans après ?" Quel est ? Et ben on trouve
il trouve souvent il trouve quelque
chose dans un bouquin. Il trouve même
des choses sur la table par exle pour
Claude Guéant. Et en effet euh il y a un
tel une telle déconnexion du pouvoir et
les atours du pouvoir euh que là ils ne
se rendent même plus compte que bah oui,
en fait on peut vivre tranquillement
dans ce monde-là en retirant en disant
que 800 € 800 € en 10ant et en payant
tout ce qu'on a à payer de sa vie privée
en cash et parfois voire même souvent en
billet de 500 en billet de 500 € et ça
n'est pas déclaré. Tout ça est
complètement hors sol du point de vue
des textes des textes réglementaires.
Mais on peut aussi
et c'est sidérant se s'acheter un très
bel appartement derrière l'Ac de
Triomphe. Ça c'est toujours Claude Guéan
en mars 2008. C'est 3 mois après la
visite de Kaddafi
qui l'a pas payé très cher d'ailleurs
qu'il a payé 700000 € pour un un 90 un
90 m² et il a amené 500000 € qui sont
arrivés sur son compte en banque
20 jours plus tôt juste avant l'achat
devant le devant le notaire en faisant
croire que cet argent provenait de la
vente de petites toiles d'un d'un
peintre hollandais. Bon, des toiles qui
valaient euh plus de plus de 10 fois
moins
30000 €.
Voilà. En fait en fait cet argent c'est
un montage qui passe par le truchement
de société euh offshore euh dont le prix
a été compensé par qui ? par la Libye et
le cash investigation le montrait bien
et nous on l'avait raconté il y a déjà
plusieurs années dans le journal, mais
on peut factuellement dire aujourd'hui
que la Libye est liée à l'achat de
Claude Guéan et il a cru que ça allait
marcher.
Je j'ouvre une parenthèse sur la class.
quand on fait l'addition de tout ça, euh
on va dire les 800000 € pour son
appartement, euh son train de vie euh de
ministre, on va dire, payer en cash, ça
fait pas ça fait pas grand-chose en fin
de compte, ça fait quelques millions
d'euros.
Bah, ça fait déjà beaucoup pour beaucoup
de gens.
Non, mais pour la uper class série hein.
Ah bah, par rapport à un monde qui
peuvent fréquenter, oui, c'est c'est
peu. Mais
parlons de ce monde là,
c'est ce qu'on trouve.
Ouais, parlons de ce monde là. le monde
des paradis fiscaux, le monde de la
concentration du pouvoir, le monde des
yautes de plus de 100 m 100 m de long.
Vous connaissez ce monde là un peu ?
Non,
jamais.
Une petite soirée cocaïne
Saint-Bart. Jamais.
Jamais. Non, je le Non,
moi je je pars du principe que mon
boulot, c'est de raconter le monde tel
qu'il est. Donc mon boulot, c'est pas de
me boucher le nez euh pour aller
comprendre comment ça se passe. C'estàd
ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que
euh je me fais honneur dans mon dans mon
téléphone, dans mon carnet d'adresse euh
d'avoir euh des corrompus, des
corrupteurs, euh des gens de peu, des
gens de bien, des gens qui ont fait de
la prison, des braqueurs, des gens qu'
sont passés en cours d'assise, des
ministres, pourquoi pas des présidents,
des agents secrets, des policiers, des
magistrats, peu importe, des
syndicalistes, chef d'entreprise et
cetera et cetera et cetera. Et vous avez
un iPhone ?
Et ouais, j'ai un iPhone. Et c'est pas
C'est un scandale.
Voilà, c'est pas le bon lieu pour le
dire.
Euh voilà. Donc bien évidemment
quand j'essaie d'écrire sur des
escroqueries, par exemple l'escroquerie
dite à la taxe carbone sur laquelle j'ai
beaucoup écrit, ben je fréquente les
escroc. Donc j'essaie de fréquenter leur
milieu. J'essaie de voilà, ça veut pas
dire pour pour répondre pour pas. Non
mais ah non mais moi je je je n'ai
d'abord aucune fascination. J'ai aucune
fascination. J'ai pas d'âé. J'ai pas
d'âéit du tout là-dessus du tout. Euh et
donc euh mais j'ai jamais je me suis
jamais retrouvé sur une ce serait un
Gonzo génial hein. Moi j'adorerais me
retrouver sur une soirée genre le Lou
Wall Street et à raconter en étant à
côté de DiCaprio, enfin le le plutôt son
personnage qui joue, comment ça se
passe. Plein de journalistes font ça
hyper bien notamment dans les pays
anglo-saxons. Voilà, j'ai j'ai pas de
pas j'ai aucun surplom par rapport par
rapport à ça. En revanche, je connais ce
monde là par les éléments et notamment
documentaires qu'on récupère sur ces je
sais ce que c'est un ya, je sais combien
ça coûte, je sais comment ça se finance,
je sais ce qu'on peut y faire, notamment
ces liens faussement d'amitié qui sont
des liens de cupidité, qui sont des
liens de corruption, hein. C'est c'est
c'est par là que commence la corruption.
Le le lefeu
ou Jean-François Copé sur le Y de
Takedine, c'est le début de la
corruption. C'est le début de la
corruption quand l'un est au ministère
de l'intérieur, l'autre au ministère du
budget, l'homme est marchand d'armes.
C'est l'un des plus gros frudeur fiscaux
qu'on qu'on connaisse.
Et il y a des photos sur le yach avec
les femmes, on les voit ou dans la
piscine. fameuse photo de Copé là qu'on
avait rendu publique de Copé Barbotant
en quelque sorte dans la fraude fiscale
puisque la piscine et toute la maison au
Cap d'Antiib faisait partie d'un d'un
énorme montage frauduleux hein du point
de vue du fils qui a réclamé depuis je
crois plus d'une vingtaine de millions
d'euros à à à Takédine après nos après
nos nos révélations. Donc c'est c'est un
monde dont les mondanités
euh sont parfois le le marche-pied de la
corruption, hein. Ça n'est pas que du
plaisir. C'est c'est c'est dans ces
moments qu'on fait des photos et puis
les photos, bah c'est embêtant. Voilà.
C'est peut-être comme ça qu'il se
tiennent.
Ça peut être notamment comme ça, bien
sûr.
Puis ils peuvent faire d'autres choses
aussi, non ?
Bah je sais pas après ça. Oui. Oui. On
peut faire plein de choses.
Ouais. Or la loi.
Je sais pas. Peut-être. Je sais pas.
Revenons. Revenons à notre affaire. Euh
quand on voit Sarkozy euh pousser des
grands cris d'or frais, euh
ça ça t'a fait quoi de de voir ça ?
Genre il raconte n'importe quoi, méia
part le document était faux. Euh ça
passe à TF1. Ouais ouais, ça passe à Ben
moi j'ai un avocat en droit de la presse
là avec qui je m'entends bien,
Christophe Bigot qui est un super avocat
qui voilà
qui qui est l'avocat qui avait relu le
le livre pour FAR qui est spécialisé
notamment dans les maisons d'édition qui
est un mec absolument génial et il
m'avait il m'avait appelé après le
passage de TF1, il m'avait dit "J'espère
que vous allez demander un droit de
réponse équivalent pour passer". C'était
un peu une boutane mais c'était en en
droit, c'était pas c'était pas c'était
pas faux parce que euh on a compté hein,
il a il a cité 10 fois Media Part 20h de
de TF1 fois. Bah c'est super en même
temps on a un tâché de presse absolument
formidable. çait déjà c'est déjà le cas
pendant l'affaire béton en cours. Donc
on va surtout pas lui demander d'arrêter
ça. Euh mais en fait ce qui était
incroyable après sa mise en examen,
c'est de voir un ancien président de la
République alors qui sur la forme est et
bon il est il est impressionnant quoi.
Il est il fait il est il est vigoureux,
il est droit dans ses bottes dans la
forme, il est hyper combatif, il est
même violent dans d'un point de vue
symbolique la façon dont il s'exprime et
cetera. Mais en réalité sur le fond ce
qu'il raconte c'est un bullshit de A à
Z. Il y a pas un truc factuel qu'il a
dit sur le 20h de TF1 qui est vrai. Pas
un truc. Même quand il dit qu'il a
appris que il allait être placé en garde
à vue le matin même. C'est faux. même ça
c'est faux. Voilà. En fait, il savait
depuis un mois et demi he qu'il allait
être entendu comme mise en cause par les
policiers. Donc il a eu le temps et les
les policiers ont agit comme des
gentleman. Il a eu le temps de préparer
son audition. Bon, il a eu un mois et
demi pour le faire. D'ailleurs, il
connaît le dossier par cœur quand il
arrive quand il arrive en garde à vue.
D'ailleurs, il arrive avec sous le bras
pour la petite anecdote avec notre livre
qu'on a fait avec Lasque dont je parlais
tout à l'heure. Il vient avec notre
livre pour dire à quel point c'est bon.
Mais en fait, on a un Sarkozy qui fait
semblant, il est pas bête. En plus,
c'est un ancien avocat et toujours
avocat. Euh il fait semblant parce qu'il
pense que ce qu'il lui faut gagner c'est
la bataille de l'opinion publique. Il
fait semblant de croire que son problème
c'est médiia part. Pour ça qu'il nous
déchire et il veut dire en fait il dit
caddafist
euh euh sont des dictateurs, c'est des
tueurs. Médiiapard c'est des faussères.
Takedine c'est un fou. Il fait du
cuisine. C'est
c'est ça ça. C'est ça. C'est une
stratégie comme si comme si les juges
français, trois des plus grands
magistrats français, la police
anticorruption, le parquet allait
décider de d'accuser et de mettre en
examen un ancien président de la
République en faisant confiance
aveuglément à l'ancien régime
dictatorial, en faisant confiance
aveuglément à Takédine ou en ne se
basant que sur les enquêtes de médiia
part. Juste un tout petit peu de respect
pour pour les magistrats et les
policiers qui bossent depuis 5 ans sur
ce dossier. C'est quand même un ancien
président, un ancien ministre de
l'intérieur. Mais en fait son problème
c'est plus Média Part là. Il s'est cru
en 2012. Il a cru qu'il était dans une
campagne présidentielle ou je sais pas
quoi. Mais c'est nous c'est fini en
fait. On n plus sans problème. Son
problème s'appelle les juges. C'est
devant eux qu'il va falloir qu'il se
batte. Et il a il a le droit de se
battre et évidemment qui il a le droit
de contester sa mise sa mise en examen.
Il a le droit avec tous les moyens de la
loi de se battre et c'est bien la
moindre des choses. Et il est présumé
innocent. Mais non seulement il se
trompe d'adversaire et en plus quand il
essaie d'avancer des pions factuels,
c'est totalement bidon. J'ouvre j'ouvre
deux parenthèses. La première c'est
tu fais la 4e.
Ouais bon t'inquiète pas, il nous reste
une heure et demi. Euh la première c'est
le cash qui circule pendant la campagne.
Euh euh énormément de cach. Tout le
monde reçoit des petites enveloppes à
gauche à droite.
Ça t'a pas posé des des des problèmes en
sachant qu'il y a quand même des
services de renseignement en France qui
doivent avoir un œil dans les campagnes,
qui doivent voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe, que tout le monde ferme sa gueule
pour être trivial.
Euh alors service d'enseignement, c'est
la crainte.
Non, service de renseignement, je sais
pas. Mais
est-ce que tu te rappelles la fusion
entre la DCI et la la DST ? Voilà. Éerg,
pardon,
où il y a eu où il y a eu un bon
écrémage de tous les antisarcosistes.
Euh juste au au même moment, est-ce que
est-ce que tu tu penses que
ils ont même mis la main sur les
services de renseignement pour faire
taire ce qui se passait ? Alors, il y a
il y a deux questions. Il y a la
question euh de du cash, du contrôle et
la question de de
la privatisation
privatisation du du renseignement. Bon,
euh moi je sais pas ce que les services
de renseignement, j'ai pas d'éléments.
Donc, je sais pas sur la campagne
présidentielle de 2007. Je vais répondre
sur les deux questions. Prenons le le le
cach.
En effet, il y a eu un usage immodéré du
cash, hein. C'est c'est il y a eu une
abondance une abondance de d'enveloppe
en liquide dans cette dans cette
campagne. Et d'ailleurs, il y a une une
petite anecdote qui pour moi enfin qui
n'est pas qu'anecdotique d'ailleurs est
très bavarde et résume tout dans ce dans
ce dossier. L'homme qui est le directeur
de la campagne, c'est Claude Guérand.
Bon, c'est aussi l'homme qui est le plus
en lien avec le régime libire avec
Takédin. Il se voit tout le temps, il
s'appelle, ils s'écrivent des notes et
bon tout ça a été retrouvé hein, d'abord
par Médiap par puis par la police. Euh
et bien cet homme qui est directeur de
campagne Gan, le temps de la campagne
présidentielle, il ouvre une chambre
forte dans une banque. Bon, pour la
petite anecdote, il est à la BNP, lui
est client de la BNP. Il va à son
agence, je crois que c'est c'est un
Philippe DU, mais je suis plus sûr de
ça. En tout cas, il va à son agence à
Paris et dit voilà moi je veux un coffre
fort. Il disent bah voilà monsieur Géan,
bien sûr on a un coffre fort et tout ça.
Donc il lui montre dit non non mais moi
il m'en faut un très très grand. Ah ben
non mais nous ça on a pas ici. Il faut
aller à l'agence Opéra. L'agence Opéra
c'est la grande agence l'agence vitrine
un peu de la BNP à Paris. Bon il va
là-bas il lui ouvre une chambre forte si
grande qu'un homme peut y rentrer
debout. hein. Donc c'est pas rien, c'est
un truc immense. Bon euh il ouvre le
temps de la campagne, il la ferme à la
fin de la campagne et le temps de la
campagne, il y va sep fois. On sait pas
ce qu'il va chercher mais il y va sep
fois. Quand il est entendu en garde à
vue euh on lui demande "Mais qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait dans cette chambre forte
?"
Voilà, il a dit il y avait euh des
documents du ministère de l'intérieur et
des discours de Nicolas Sarkozi. Bon,
évidemment, tout le personnel de la
campagne qui a été entendu par les
policiers euh c'est euh au mieux à
opposer une sorte de silence extrêmement
embarrassé aux enquêteurs euh au pire
euh pour lui était euh enfin se bidonner
quoi. Il y a vraiment des des réactions
sur procès verbal. Il disent mais c'est
hallucinant. les les discours en fait,
ils étaient disponibles sur l'intranet
de de Nicolas Sarkozy et quel est
l'intérêt d'aller mettre des documents
de travail dans une banque qui a des
horaires de fermeture
alors qu'on pourrait les avoir au QG de
la campagne qui est sécurisé où il y a
aussi d'ailleurs des chambres fortes ?
Bon, évidemment évidemment les
enquêteurs ont un peu de mal à penser
qu'il y avait simplement du papier et
des discours mais en tout cas une autre
forme de papier dans ces dans ces
coffres. Bon, Vert, Eric Wert qui était
le trésorier de la campagne
présidentielle
en 2007, il a été entendu dans le dans
le dossier, il a dit "Ouais, ouais, il y
avait c'est vrai qu'il y avait du cash."
Euh en fait, on c'était des dons
anonymes qu'on recevait par la poste,
hein. Par par la poste. Voilà. Bon,
alors pas de pot. Le chef du courrier de
l'UMP a été entendu. Bon et il dit "On
n'a jamais reçu d'enveloppe avec des
billets de 200, des billets de 500
anonymement par la poste." On imagine le
gars qui va ou la nana qui va financer
une campagne électorale et qui va mettre
500 € et les envoyer. Bon, tout ça n'a
absolument aucun sens et ça a été
démenti. Alors Vert, il a il a
conscience du problème, il dit c'était
que 35000 €. Bon, en réalité, au regard
de de l'enquête, c'est inchiffrable
parce qu'on parle de centaines et
centaines et centaines de de
d'enveloppes et c'est inchiffrable.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est pour ça qu'on
utilise le cash, c'est parce que ça ne
laisse pas de traçabilité le cash. C'est
exactement la raison. Et pour répondre à
la question, il y a normalement une
commission de contrôle des comptes de
campagne en France. Mais en fait, c'est
le moyen-âge cette commission. Elle a
pas de moyens d'enquête. Euh, elle fait
la preuve à chaque élection de son
impuissance. C'est quand même la
commission qui a raté juste plus de 20
millions d'euros de de fausses factures
dans l'affaire Big Malon, hein, en 2012.
Paul Bismut.
Voilà. Bon, c'est-à-dire que l'affaire
Big Malion nous a quand même montré
qu'une campagne présidentielle pouvait
coûter plus du double du plafond
autorisé. Bon, donc on voit à peu près
ce qu'il a pu se passer dans l'affaire
des financements lib pour pour 2007. Et
donc là, il y a une atrophie très très
française du contrepouvoir vis-à-vis de
cette commission qui n'a de contrôle en
réalité que le nom, qui par ailleurs
fait tout pour ne pas demander de moyens
à une classe politique qui est
absolument ravi de ne pas les les lui
donner pour travailler. Bon voilà.
Ensuite, il y a la question du des
services de renseignement et c'est vrai
que tout ça se passe dans un moment très
très restreint qui est entre 2005 et
2007. le moment où Sarkozy à part un
petit passage de 4 mois à Ber et
ministre de l'intérieur et en effet il
fait cette fusion des RG et du
contreespionnage la DST la direction de
surveillance du territoire pour créer ce
que Squartini qui était son premier
patron appelé le FBI à la française la
la DCRI dont le premier dossier est
quand même un fiasco majeur l'affaire de
Tarnac dit de Tarnac quand même le
premier dossier de la DCRI on a vu ce
qu'il en a coûté pour pour le la
notoriété de ce service avec la relaxe
de ces de ces de ces dernières semaines.
Et en effet, on a vu que la DCRI à mains
égards, il s'agit pas de de jeter tous
les agents, il y a des gens absolument
formidables qui bossent là-bas, des gens
qui qui luttent contre le terrorisme. A
des gens qui comptent pas leurs heures,
des fonctionnaires absolument
extraordinaires. Il s'agit vraiment pas
vraiment pas vraiment pas de dire qu'il
y a des bons bien sûr. mon
c'est vraiment absolument pas mon mon
propos mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu sous
Sarkozy une volonté de faire de la DCRI
la brigade du chef et alors là j'ai une
autre anecdote très courte mais mais qui
mais qui pour moi dit oui pardon je dis
très court parce que je habitué aux
interviews, faut faire court
mais qui dit tout de de cela et qui est
dans l'affaire libienne. Sarkozi en
2013, il est plus président mais il
panique littéralement, il panique au
sujet du témoignage d'un d'un homme
qu'on a vu dans le cach investigation
qu'on avait interviewé dans Media Part
qui est le traducteur de Kaddafi, hein,
professeur,
le professeur Moftami Sourri qui est
diplomate hein, à laquelle contre qui il
n'y a jamais rien eu.
le les anticadfises on jamais poursuivi,
la France l'a jamais poursuivi,
quelqu'un de très honorable entre
guillemets
et qui a été bah les yeux, les oreilles
et la bouche de Kaddafi dans les
relations françaises pendant pendant des
pendant des des décennies. Bon euh et
Sarkozy était paniqué euh sur l'éventuel
témoignage en 2013 que cet homme pouvait
pouvait livrer à la justice voire vo
voir voir au journalistes.
Et ce qu'il fait c'est qu'il appelle à
deux reprises. Il est plus président
hein, je quand même imaginer la la
scène. Il appelle le chef des services
secrets de la DCRI qui est s'appelle
Patrick Calvar
et il lui demande ce qu'ils ont sur
Moftamouri.
Bon et Calvar est hyper prudent et il
répond pas. Il dit oui monsieur le
président, il l'appelle quand même
monsieur le président mais plus le
président mais voilà et puis en fait il
rappelle pas et Sarkozi appelle son son
chef de cabinet parce que en tant que
ancien président il a quand même un
cabinet il a quand même un chef de
cabinet chef de cabinet qui pour la
petite anecdote et il s'appelle Michel
Godin c'est l'ancien patron de la police
nationale. Ça montre un peu le le prisme
de Sarkozy qu'il lui faut un patron de
la police comme chef de cabinet en tant
qu'ancien président. Euh bon, il
l'appelle Godin SarkoZi et il est
énervé. Il dit "Mais mais Calvar il
rappelle pas et cetera et il a cette
phrase exceptionnelle. Sarkoi, il dit
points vrai les guillemets, mais il nous
est fidèle lui.
C'estàd que l'ancien président de la
République parlant du patron des
services secrets intérieurs à son chef
de cabinet demande si de point V
guillemets est-ce qu'il nous est fidèle
lui. Si c'est pas une phrase mafieuse
ça, j'assume. Si c'est pas une phrase
mafieuse, c'est quoi ? Bon mais pourquoi
il dit ça ? Parce que pour répondre à la
question sur les services de
renseignement, oui, sous SarkoZi, je
sais pas si c'est plus en tout cas que
pour d'autres gouvernements ou d'autres
présidences,
la cellule de l'Élysée Souitéran, on a
vu ce que ce que c'était le le patron du
journal pour lequel je travaille, Edou
Pénal, était quand même le journaliste
le plus écouté euh par Miteran. Mais
sous SarkoZi, en effet, on a considéré
que les services secrets, en tout cas
intérieurs, étaient sa chose. C'était la
brigade du chef. Voilà. Et c'est pour ça
qu'il se sent impunément
capable de dire en 2013 "Mais est-ce
qu'il nous est fidèle lui ?" Et ça pour
moi, ça dit tout. C'est c'est le le
petit événement qui c'est la leçon de
choses parfaites de l'état d'esprit de
certains au pouvoir face à ce type de
dossier.
On va revenir à notre affaire.
qu'on a d'ailleurs pas quitté.
Euh on a on a Sarkozi qui a nommé un
pseudo ambassadeur bodybuildé qui a
manqué de respect au monde arabe tout
entier qui s'est fait toper avec
énormément d'argent liquide la guerre du
Nord
avec des billets qui étaient
avec des numéros de série qui se
suivaient.
Ouais. Ouais.
La Banque centrale européenne est
capable de dire d'où ça vient.
Ouais. La banque centrale européne la
personne en question c'est Boris Boyon.
C'est un homme qui doit toute sa
carrière à Sarkozy. Voilà, il était déjà
avec Sarkozy au ministère de
l'intérieur. C'est déjà le conseiller
diplomatique de Sarkozy au ministère de
de l'intérieur. C'est devenu son cherpa
comme on dit, un conseiller diplomatique
à l'Élysée. Puis après, il a eu une
carrière d'ambassadeur. Voilà. Bon, on
le voit
dans le reportage de Cach Investigation,
ils ont retrouvé une image d'archive
incroyable où on le voit là comme les
pompiers là faire la planche. Bon, en
effet, c'est c'est un peu l'ambassadeur
en slip de bain parce que voilà, il
voilà, il était en slip et tout ça. Bon,
très un peu James Bond et il allait sur
des formes extraordinaires.
Ouais. Ah bon, ça je
Et c'est vrai que ce Boris Voyon s'est
fait choper comme un bleu en juillet
2013, Garde du Nord. Euh, il allait
montrer dans le Talis qui allait
l'amener à Bruxelles et là, il y a des
douiniers qui lui ont tapé sur l'épaule.
Bonjour monsieur. Alors, il était
habillé en jean polo. Il avait pas de
téléphone sur lui, il avait pas de
papier sur lui, pas de papier
d'identité. Il avait juste, si je peux
me permettre, juste deux cartes bleues
sur lequel il y avait son identité. Donc
bon, il est quand même pas si futé que
que ça a quand même son nom sur la carte
bleue. Il y en avait deux.
Et les et les douiniers lui disent c'est
une phrase réglementaire. Est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose à déclarer
supérieur à temps et cetera ? Il dit
non. Il dit bon très bien. Est-ce que
vous pouvez ouvrir ? Alors il avait un
petit sac à la main puis un sac à dos et
il ouvre et dans le sac il y a un sac.
Il ouvre le sac dans le sac. Dans dans
le sac dans le sac il y a une il y a une
un sac plastique qui l'ouvre et là il y
a 350000 € en cash et 40000 dollars en
cash sur les deux sacs confondus. Bon et
il dit Boris Voyon parce que les douers
disent bah d'où vient l'argent ? Bon
parce que déjà là de base il y a
manquement déclaratif. Bon voilà ça
c'est illégal. Blanchiment de fraude
fiscale parce que c'est de l'argent qui
est pas déclaré. Très bien. Mais il y a
d'où vient l'argent ? Quelle est
l'origine de l'argent ? Et donc il monte
un chantier pas possible en disant que
c'était de l'argent que lui avait versé
un entrepreneur iraakien parce que quand
il avait été après avoir été ambassadeur
en Irak, il avait monté une boîte de
consulting pour faire du business. Ce
qui montre d'ailleurs que on est
ambassadeur, après on pense qu'on peut
faire du business avec le pays dans
lequel on a été ambassadeur. Tout va
bien. C'est comme les conférences de
SarkoZi, tout va bien. Bon, il se trouve
qu'en fait c'est pas vrai. C'est
complètement bidon. L'entrepreneur dit
qu'il l'a jamais rémunéré, mais c'est
complètement bidon pour une raison
encore plus simple, c'est que en effet
les billets d'abord sont neufs et tous
les numéros se suivent. Et ça veut dire
une chose très simple, c'est que les
billets n'ont jamais été mis en
circulation dans l'économie réelle.
Voilà. et que ces billets proviennent de
l'eau fabriquée par des banques
centrales européennes. L'enquête a
déterminé euh que ça avait été fabriqué
par une banque centrale de mémoire la
Finlande qui a livré des palettes à
l'Irlande. Banque centrale d'Irlande
parce que les banques centrales he se
livrent de l'argent et l'Irlande
n'a pas voulu dire à quel pays elle a
livré.
Voilà, l'Irlande qui est très jalouse de
sa réputation de mauvaise coopérante
judiciaire,
c'est on parlait d'Apple tout à l'heure,
c'est quand même là que Apple cache ses
milliards he pour ne pas payer d'impôts.
C'est un pays, c'est pas un bon
partenaire du tout dans la coopération
internationale, que ce soit fiscale ou
judiciaire l'Irlande. Et l'Irlande ne
répond pas. Il n'a pas voulu répondre
d'après ce que je sais à deux reprises
au parquet de Paris pour leur dire à qui
elle a livré les palettes. Ce qu'on sait
c'est que Boris Boyon était très très
très proche des libiens. Très proche. Ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il y a un témoin
anonyme dans le dossier, un témoin
protégé. Je préfère que témoin anonyme
parce que témoin anonyme on a
l'impression que c'est une planche
pourrie qui vient raconter anonymement
des choses. Témoins protégé parce que
témoins anonyme c'est une procédure très
spéciale en France parce que la personne
est jugée crédible par les inquiéteurs
mais il faut absolument la protéger pour
des raisons de sécurité. Bon et il y a
un témoin protégé, c'est le témoin 1 2 3
he dans le dossier le témoin 123 euh qui
euh livre des éléments très
embarrassants sur Boris Boyon. Est-ce
que ça suffisera suffira à le mettre en
cause judiciairement ? J'en sais rien
mais disons que on est à ça de lier le
cach de Boris Boyon potentiellement à la
Libye. Et on sait aussi par exemple que
Boris Boyon quand il était à l'Élysée,
il a fait naturaliser la femme de Béchir
Salé, le directeur de cabinet de Kaddafi
dont je parlais tout à l'heure contre
contre l'is préfecture. On a les
courriers, on les a rendu public. La
préfecture a dit, "Elle remplit pas les
critères. Elle ne remplit pas les
critères. Elle remplit à ce point pas
les critères que cette femme a été
condamnée pour esclavage hein moderne
contre contre des domestiques qui
vivaient mais dans une indignité totale
parce qu'ils avaient une maison les
salées en Suisse en France à la
frontière à la frontière suisse vers
Ferné Voltaire. Bon et bien il y a un
courrier signé Boris Boyon à en tête de
l'IS qui fait pression sur la
préfecture. La préfecture dit non nous
on fera pas. Elle remplit pas les
critères, on la naturalise pas.
Encore des bons fonctionnaires quand
même.
Et bien sûr bien sûr on a des
fonctionnaires fabuleux fabuleux. Euh et
elle a quand même été naturalisée.
Voilà, au journal officiel, elle a été
faite française par la grâce de Boris
Boyon et donc de Nicolas Sarkozy puisque
c'était la prolongation de voilà. Et
donc là, bah oui, euh les billets quand
on les chope, c'est ça qui est rare,
c'est de choper les billets. B sur
Royon, on a chopé les billets. Le cash
de la campagne, on sait pas où il est.
Évidemment, ce cash, il est hors
comptabilité. On va pas le retrouver 10
ans après. Là, on a trouvé des billets
de Boris Boyon et bien on a encore une
espèce de métastructure de parastructure
qui empêche la vérité totale d'éclater.
Et ça c'est c'est c'est sidérant. C'est
sidérant.
Revenons à l'intervention de de Sarkozy
sur TF1.
Il a cherché clairement à avoir
l'opinion publique dans sa poche en se
victimisant face à Médiapart. Et
comment on fait nous la plebe
pour s'endurcir face à la propagande
politique et la propagande de guerre ?
Ouais. Ben c'est un enjeu capital parce
que de fait c'est une c'est une audience
importante. Voilà le 20h de TF1. Euh
c'est pour ça que par exemple à titre
personnel et c'est mon mon petit niveau,
mais dès le lendemain, j'ai j'ai bon, il
y a des médias qui me l'ont proposé donc
j'ai été content mais j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion de faire la matinale de
France Interre puis Jean-Jacques Bourdin
qui sont des des matinales très écoutées
pour croiser le fer avec ce que Sarkozy
avait dit la la veille parce que c'était
totalement faux. Donc comment on fait
les citoyens ? Bah, on essaie de
s'informer auprès de de ceux qui ont des
éléments. Il s'agit pas de nous croire
sur parole. He, c'est moi, je suis
contre le régime de la croyance, le
régime des faits. Et donc quand on
essaie de documenter, on a fait un
article moins de 24 heures après dans
Mediapard pour dire bah voilà, telle
phrase de Sarkozy, c'est faux. Telle
phrase de Sarkozy, c'est faux. Voici
pourquoi telle phrase c'est faux. Voici
pourquoi. Et je pense qu'il doit y avoir
une petite dizaine d'affirmations
factuelles dans la prestation de
Sarkozy. Elles sont toutes fausses.
Elles sont toutes fausses. Voilà. Et
c'est c'est d'ailleurs c'est c'est
inversement proportionnel à l'énergie
qu'il a mise qu'il a mis dans le dans
dans l'entretien pour essayer d'emporter
le l'opinion publique. Mais là aussi
enfin là je veux pas faire le le
commentateur de de PMU mais enfin pardon
mais c'est pas l'opinion publique qui le
met en examen et c'est pas c'est pas en
gagnant face à l'opinion publique. pense
dans un vieux schéma hyper vertical que
s'il convainc l'opinion publique, il y
aurait une pression de l'opinion
publique sur les trois magistrats et qui
vont se dire "Ah bah non, finalement on
va pas le mettre en examen." Enfin c'est
bon voilà, c'est pas c'est pas face
c'est pas sur Té à fin, c'est pas compte
Médiapart ou avec l'opinion publique qui
va qui va se sortir de l'affaire
libienne. Voilà, c'est en droit et c'est
sur la qualité des enquêtes.
D'accord. C'est endroit, c'est sur la
qualité des enquêtes. Quand on voit un
Jérôme Causc
monsieur le président, je n'ai jamais eu
de compte en Suisse, blab bla bla bla
bla bla et que il est pas en prison,
est-ce que c'est le même mécanisme que
SarkoZi essaie de faire ? C'est-à-dire
faire traîner, faire traîner, faire
traîner et et jamais aller en tôle ?
Oui, c'est vrai que disons que le propre
de la délinquence en col blanc, c'est
qu'elle vise des gens qui ont les moyens
des manœuvres dilatoires que beaucoup
d'entre nous n'avons pas de droits
commun d'autres dossiers. Voilà. Bon qui
qui ne concerne pas la criminalité
financière. J'appelle ça la criminalité
financière. Même si c'est pas un crime,
c'est un délit. Mais ça coûte tellement
à la société française à la fois dans le
sentiment la fatigue démocratique,
justice à deux vitesses, il y en a
qu'ont toujours plus que les autres et
cetera mais aussi ça nous coûte ça nous
coûte financièrement quand même. Ce qui
c'est pour ça moi que j'aime les
affaires. C'est pour ça que j'aime les
affaires, je vais répondre à la
question. Mais parce que les affaires,
c'est comme je prends souvent cette
cette image, c'est comme quand tu veux
mettre une une bagnole en vente
sur le marché avant, tu fais des crash
tests. Tu tu prends la bagnole et tu la
balances contre un mur avec un mannequin
dedans pour voir la solidité de la
carrosserie. Bon, une affaire, c'est ça
en fait. C'est un crash test. C'est un
crash test. Alors, il se trouve que les
mannequins, c'est nous. Voilà. Et la
carrosserie, bah c'est celle de nos
institutions, de la loi, de la classe
politique, des citoyens.
C'est tout ça ensemble. Et c'est
la démocratie en général.
Ouais. La démocratie, prenons un grand
mot, de la démocratie et les affaires
sont bien plus bavardes que les faits et
les personnes concernées. Bon, chaque
affaire est une leçon de choses
formidable de ce point de vue-là. Bon,
et euh Jérôme Causac, ça a été un cas
d'école formidable mais à à plein
d'égards. Ça a été un cas d'école.
Alors, on a beaucoup parlé du mensonge
de Jérôme Kausac. Bon, Jérôme Kausac,
c'est bon, c'est pas bien de mentir,
mais moi je comment dire, je pars du
principe que ça fait partie de la
palette des sentiments humains qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse mentir. On sait très
mal ce qu'il a fait de ce point de
vue-là, mais enfin bon, on va pas faire
semblant non plus de découvrir qu'un
ministre peut mentir. Le problème du
menteur et le problème du mensonge,
c'est qu'il a été accompagné
qu'il y a eu des gens pour le croire
sans enquêter. C'est valable pour une
partie du système médiatique, même si
c'est un mot que j'aime pas le système
médiatique, mais une partie des médias.
Voilà, je dis bien une partie et
notamment le commentariat quoi. Ceux qui
ont un avis surtout, mais enfin surtout
un avis tout le temps et cetera. Voilà.
Donc
non mais enfin bon après c'est pas des
batailles personnelles mais voilà on
voit on voit à peu près et puis par le
gouvernement on oublie toujours cet
épisode de l'affaire qui aac mais
alors que la justice enquêtaéit he on
est début janvier 2013 le parquet de
Paris est déjà en enquête préliminaire
le gouvernement a dans le dos du
procureur Molince lequel dira plus tard
devant la commission d'enquête
parlementaire que de mémoire de
magistrat au parquet il n'a jamais vu
a diligenté le gouvernement une enquête
parallèle secrète dans le dos du du
parquet auprès des autorités
administratives suisses en posant des
mauvaises questions en Suisse qui ont
répondu au gouvernement français dont la
réponse était qu'ussaac n'avait pas de
compte en Suisse. a fuité très vite au
JDD, journal ami de la sphère
qui a UAC, Foux et cetera et qui titre
en une les Suisses ont blanchis qu'àusc
et le gouvernement c'était Pierre
Moscovici quand même aujourd'hui
commissaire européen euh qui avait
oublié de prévenir le parquet de ses
diligences ne n'a pas oublié de lui
donner en revanche la réponse des
Suisses. Bon, c'était quoi ça ? Bah,
c'était juste une manœuvre pour couper
l'herbe sous le pied du procureur.
Procureur dont on rappelle, je rappelle
quand même en France qu'il est soumis
hiérarchiquement au pouvoir exécutif.
Heureusement qu'on est tombé sur un
procureur François Molins qui l'a a
préféré l'indépendance à la loyauté
hiérarchique. Parce que Molin il aurait
très bien pu avec ce document dire bon
bah fin de l'histoire OK OK bon vous
avez fait l'enquête il y a pas je classe
ensuite fini aujourd'hui là nous médiart
et moi je serai le pire des accusateurs
calomniateurs en France et Jérôme Kac
serait peut-être premier ministre ou
enfin en tout cas c'est la destinée
qu'on qu'on lui prédisait à l'époque.
Voilà, il a dit hop là non moi je vais
faire des vraies questions en Suisse
hein avec l'enquête et puis l'enquête de
médiap. faire des vraies questions puis
avec les mêmes éléments, il pose des
questions et bizarrement les Suisses il
disent "Bah si, en fait, il y a un
compte en Suisse et tout ça et cetera."
Voilà. Bon et c'est vrai pour répondre à
la question que l'affaire Causa qui est
je l'ai écrit dans le journal et ça m'a
valu d'ailleurs des débats compliqués
parfois à l'extérieur, mais j'assume
vraiment cette position de de dire
qu'elle illustre le tabou français, on
en parlait déjà un peu tout à l'heure
sur la prison dans la lutte contre la
délinquence en col blanc. Euh,
on peut tout à fait ne pas être pour le
tout carcéral, pour la prison et
d'ailleurs on voit à quel point la
prison est un lieu d'indignité en
France. La réinsertion est en faillite.
Euh foyer de radicalisation,
c'est voilà, c'est des écoles du crime.
C'est une décision tellement dure de
mettre quelqu'un en prison que
évidemment aucun magistrat ne fait ça
fait ça à la légère. Mais on peut aussi
constater he de tenir tous les bouts que
ce sont souvent les mêmes qui n'y vont
pas
et que c'est pour ça que moi je suis
pour le décentrement que dans d'autres
pays bah ça se passe pas comme ça en
fait dans d'autres pays des démocraties
libérales au sens lesquel
bah en Allemagne en Angleterre aux
États-Unis en Israël on va en prison
pour des délits qui sont des atteintes à
l'apprité et personne ne discute là-bas
de la justice robes piérerist
des juges rouges, c'est quoi
en Israël ? En ce moment, les enquêtes
concernant le licoud, il y a des
quelques freins quand même. Non.
Alors non, alors c'est un pays c'est un
pays c'est un pays bizarre Israël, c'est
un pays bizarre de ce point de vue-là.
C'est c'est un pays qui a quand même mis
son premier ministre et mert en prison
pour des bacchiches de 14000 €. 14000 €
sur un marché sur des pots de vin sur un
marché immobilier. Bon 14000 € c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas les montants dont on
parle dans l'affaire libyenne ou Big
Malion ou je ne sais quoi ou même CUSAC.
Bon euh il y a euh l'actuel premier
ministre Netaniaahou qui a été euh mise
en cause et entendu comme mise en cause
par la police dans plusieurs affaires et
il est cerné par la justice
anticorruption.
Donc c'est voilà c'est c'est un pays de
ce point de vue là qui est un pays
ambivalent. Ils font sincèrement ils
font ce qu'on fait pas. Je veux dire
Netaniaou il est il est il est il est
interrogé mis en cause par la police
anticorruption alors qu'il est en
fonction alors qu'il est en fonction en
France.
Euh bon en en Angleterre, je citais
l'Angleterre tout à l'heure, un député
qui a triché sur ses notes de frais et
triché sur not de frais, il a fait 6
mois de prise en ferme. Il s'appelle
Denise Mchanin et ça était pas le seul
hein du tout hein. Il a fait un livre
pour expliquer pourquoi c'était normal.
Bon, en Allemagne, le patron du Bayern
de Munich euh qui a fraudé le fisque des
montants très importants, il a été
condamné à 3 ans de prison ferme mais il
est allé en prison il a pas il s'est
même excusé devant le peuple allemand de
l'argent qu'il avait volé et cetera
parce que la fraude fiscale, c'est du
vol, hein. C'est ni plus ni moins que du
vol. C'est un enrichissement personnel.
un ancien gouverneur de l'Illinois aux
États-Unis
qui avait essayé de monayer un un siège
sénatorial, il a été condamné à 14 ans
de prison ferme et il est allé en
prison. Alors, il a pas fait les 14 ans,
mais il est allé en prison. Bon, euh en
France, les derniers à être allés en
prison pour des affaires d'atteinte à la
probité, c'était dans les années 90.
C'était Carignon, c'était l'ancien
secrétaire d'État Boucheron. Voilà. Et
depuis, bah il y a il y a pas eu et le
jugement qu' a eu Zac en première
instance, il a été condamné à 3 ans de
prison ferme. Donc il était certain avec
une peine pareille de faire au moins
quelques mois à l'ombre. Et en appel, il
a été condamné à 4 ans de prison. Alors
on a l'impression que c'est aggravé mais
en fait non. seulement deux avec du
ferme, donc deux avec surcis. Euh et 2
ans de prison ferme, c'est le palier qui
permet de d'aménager la peine. Bon, donc
aujourd'hui, il est ce qu'on peut dire,
ce qu'il est plus du tout certain
d'aller en prison comme c'était le cas
en première instance. C'était exactement
ce qu'il voulaient parce que la seule la
chose dont ils ont le plus peur, c'est
ça l'exemplarité de leur point de vue.
C'est ça, c'est la c'est la prison qui
fait peur. Et donc là maintenant, il va
se il va être présenté devant un juge
d'application des peines et la
probabilité que celui-ci l'envoie
derrière les barreaux est quasi proche
de zéro. Voilà.
On se fait une petite parenthèse. Euh,
on a vu émerger ces derniers temps des
décodex, des fact check, des listes
blanches de médias
patentés et accrédités pour déterminer
ce qui était la réalité. Est-ce que tu
as un point de vue là-dessus sur ceux
qui déterminent la liste,
les gens au sein de cette liste là et
les répercussions sur l'esprit critique
du public ?
C'est une question hyper importante et
très compliquée.
C'est-à-dire que
moi j'ai enfin j'ai aucun problème avec
le facting.
Tout ça me paraît extrêmement sain
d'essayer de vérifier où où se situe les
faits par rapport à la propagande par
rapport voilà. Après euh
propagande de quel côté ?
Bah je sais pas n'importe lesquel. La
propagande gouvernementale, la
propagande d'entreprise propagande
syndicale, la propagande militante
voilà.
Peu importe, il y a des propagandes et
il y a des euh il y a des informations
qui comme le Canada Drag ont la couleur,
l'odeur mais n'en sont pas et donc c'est
bien que des journalistes viennent dire
bah non voilà l'effet c'est ça.
Après, il faut pas qu'il y ait des
effets de loupe avec le fact checking où
en fait c'est pas 2 %, c'est 3 % et que
le débat public soit capté par des
batailles d'apothicaires
autour d'une réduction du fact checking
à simplement ce type de petite algarade
de chiffres. Voilà. Mais euh sur la
fonction euh sociale et intellectuelle
et utile aux citoyens. De toute façon,
moi je je suis pour voilà, on fait on
après, il y a la question des euh en
effet des listes, les médias qu'on peut
qu'on conseille de lire.
J'en vois bien le l'utilité dans un
moment où le complotisme saisit beaucoup
la jeunesse, les réseaux sociaux et
cetera et cetera, mais comme s'il y
avait un danger permanent du peuple
numérique. Ce qui ce qui me gêne un peu
moi, cette idée-là, parce que
les les les plus gros producteurs de
fake news, c'est quand même les
gouvernements.
Enfin, je je
ou les journalistes
ou Oui. ou ça peut être les journalistes
mais le enfin quand même je enfin
oublions pas que une grande partie des
pays occidentaux sont partis faire la
guerre en Irak sur la foi d'une énorme
fake news américaine. Voilà aussi non ?
Et en Libye il y a eu de très grosses
fake news. Euh bah par exemple en Libye
il a été dit ça a fait le tour du monde
chacun pourra retrouver.
Il a été dit que Kaddafi
a envoyé son aviation bombarder Tripoli
en février 2011. C'est pas BHL qui
si si BHL a relayé tout ça et et bon la
scène selon laquelle l'aviation libyenne
a bombardé des populations civiles le 21
février 2011 qui est une information qui
était sortie dans Alzira sur la foi d'un
témoignage euh téléphonique dont on
voyait pas le le visage de la de la
personne qui a fait le tour du monde he
ça fait des urgents et cetera voilà
cette scène n'existe pas hein cette
scène n'existe pas et c'est c'est elle
existe pas à tel point que l'ambassadeur
français en Libye, François Gouillette à
l'époque est entendu quelques jours plus
tard au Parlement, il dit "Cette scène
n'existe pas. Le ministre de la défense,
Robert Gates et le chef d'état-major de
l'armée américaine qui sont entendu au
Sénat début mars 2011 disent "Cette
scène n'existe pas." Cette scène
n'existe pas. Voilà. Et pourtant,
partout, il a été dit et chacun qui a un
peu en souvenir la guerre en Libye croit
que Kaddafi a bombardé des population
civile. En fait, ça n'est pas vrai.
Alors, ça fait pas de Kaddafi un
démocrate. Ça fait je pas bon c'était un
tyran. Mais bon, mais ça c'est pas vrai.
Voilà, c'est pas vrai. Et moi j'ai j'ai
rencontré pour le livre dont je parlais
tout à l'heure Bernard Henry Lévi
que je crois sincère dans sa démarche
comment dire de se prendre un peu pour
pour Malerot quoi. C'est-à-dire c'est ce
qu'il a raconté dans son livre La guerre
sans l'aimer que bah voilà il a
un chef-dœuvre.
un journal en costume de soi-même, quoi.
Et et il avait il avait comme ça le le
avec la guerre en Libye le la situation
paroxistique de la guerre juste, de son
concept de guerre juste, comme si il
suffisait de de penser politiquement
juste, à savoir qu'adafi est un tyran
pour que la guerre soit juste, comme si
c'était aussi simple que ça. Bon, mais
peut-être il est sincère et moi je suis
pas dans le secret des âmes des gens
ici. Voilà, en revanche dans notre
entretien et c'est dans le livre et il a
même validé la citation. Donc bon, il
pourra pas j'ai un mail d'ailleurs, il
l'a jamais démenti, hein, depuis
l'automne dernier. Il dit "Oui, c'est
vrai, il y a pas eu de massacre de
population civile." Or, il disait
l'inverse. Alors après, il est très
habile hein. Il dit "Mais justement, il
y a pas des il y a sa phrase d'après,
c'est il y a pas d'histoire des
catastrophes évitées. C'est précisément
pour ça qu'on fit des guerres
préventives et cetera." Enfin quand même
quand même il y a moi je pensais que
cette phrase de BHL allait faire un peu
événement quand le livre est sorti. Bon,
elle est passée un peu inaperçu, mais
bon, c'est dans le livre. Oui, il y
avait pas de massacre. C'est vrai, il y
avait pas de massacre de population
civile. Bon, euh, il y a eu un début de
guerre civile. Je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, il y a eu il y a eu une
insurrection, il y a eu une répression
par le régime Kaddafi, il y a pas il y a
pas de doute. Mais le génocide en route
ou le massacre de population civile, ça
c'était des fake news qu'on qu'on a
qu'on a accompagné. et on peut regarder
cette histoire là avec euh les avec un
regard maintenant un peu plus clinique
et un peu plus froid. Donc pour revenir
à notre discussion,
on pourra rajouter juste avant les
charniers Timisoara. Ah bah oui, bien
sûr, les charniers, bien sûr, bien sûr.
Euh
pour revenir à la question,
ouais, sur les listes de de journaux,
euh
c'est toujours compliqué de de savoir
qui fait la liste, selon quel critère,
euh
et puis où ça commence et où ça
s'arrête, quoi. C'est-à-dire que
c'est à la fois les par les promoteurs
qui font ça l'idée d'accompagner
l'esprit critique du lecteur et sa
vigilance vis-à-vis de du tout numérique
et de voilà et en même temps et en même
temps je trouve qu'il y a un risque
potentiel précisément de priver le
citoyen de son libre arbitre. Voilà. Et
et chacun a est libre de lire ce qu'il a
envie de lire. Euh et moi je j'essaie de
faire des interventions par exemple dans
les collèges, les lycées, tout ça.
Les écoles de journalisme.
Alors les écoles de journalisme, je
passe le bonjour à l'école de tour. J'y
vais d'autant plus que que moi j'y suis
jamais allé. J'ai pas j'ai pas de
diplôme si ce n'est le baccalauréat.
Donc voilà. Donc moi, je connais pas ce
qu'on y apprend et cetera, mais et mais
je voulais parler des personnes plus
jeunes, par exemple, des collégiens ou
des ou des lycéens.
Je déteste qu'on qu'on les prenne de
haut sur les questions du complotisme,
par exemple, disant c'est pas bien de
penser ça. Voilà. Bien sûr que le
complotisme, bien sûr que les fake news,
bien sûr que la propagande, bien sûr que
des puissances comme la puissance russe
ou d'autres euh des régimes autoritaires
peuvent propager
ou américains. Mais je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, la guerre en Irak, bien sûr
tout ça, mais euh et je je
enfin j'aime pas cette idée de d'aller
voir des gamins, les voir de haut avec
sorte de surplomb en disant "C'est mal
de penser comme ça."
Je prenons les choses à l'envers.
Partons du principe que le complotisme
entre guillemets,
il y a une part qui est une part
critique du monde tel qu'on nous le
présente. Voilà, ça veut pas dire
évidemment qu'il faut croire et tomber
dans le régime de la croyance, mais la
meilleure façon de lutter contre le
complotisme, c'est d'aller au fond des
faits avec ces gens. Dire voilà les
quels sont quelle est la base factuelle
de ce qui est raconté. tu es tu es du
genre à vouloir t'inoculer une part
pour pouvoir te rendre euh plus
résistant.
Ouais. En tout cas euh moi je pense que
c'est que en se coltinant à ça qu'on
peut le résoudre. C'est pas en se
bouchant le nez en disant voilà et euh
moi je je j'aime discuter avec des des
des jeunes sur les théories
complotistes.
Lesquelles ?
Mais n'importe que ce soit autour d'un
attentat. les vaccins machin
ou les vaccins ou même parfois les plus
folles, hein. Euh, je veux dire
comme la Terre est plate.
Ouais. Le le la Terre est plate, euh les
Illuminati, les euh les euh comment les
les serpents là euh comment s'appelle ?
Euh
les reptiliens.
Les reptiliens, c'est il y a des
empreintes énormes de ces trucs-là. Bon
euh mais de la même manière que il y a
120 ans, il y avait le protocole des
sages deion qui a nourri l'antisémitisme
moderne depuis depuis des des décennies.
Bon, mais moi je pense que tout ça
se regarde cas par cas, au fait et on
démonte patiemment tout ça et et je
pense que entraîner notamment ces
jeuneslà dans l'exercice de
déconstruction, bah ça les ça les
valorise à fond et c'est la c'est le
meilleur vaccin contre ça. Mais bien
sûr, ça les endurcit et donc voilà,
s'ils se posent des questions, ils ont
pas envie de croire à quelque chose. Bah
d'abord, c'est pas une croyance puis
regardons. Vous dites les Kachi, c'est
pas vrai. Il y avait le F le
rétroviseur. Bah prenons les faits,
prenons les faits un par un et
regardons. Et ça se démonte tout ça, ça
se démonte tranquillement et c'est comme
ça qu'on gagne, je crois la la la
bataille de de l'info.
Revenons. On voudrait on voudrait ton
point de vue sur les manipulations
d'élection, l'astro turfing,
les usines à troll,
la réaction de de ta corporation, est-ce
que tu la trouves saine, pas saine ?
Est-ce que tu penses que le journalisme
n'est pas dans un état de décitude ?
Est-ce que le journalisme ne va pas à
volot ? Est-ce que le journalisme n'a
pas la laisse du pouvoir qui se tend
beaucoup plus qu'avant sur le collier de
la presse ? Est-ce que le fait qu'il y
ait une concentration de la presse dans
les mains d'oligarque
français, ça devient un petit peu,
trouvons un bon mot,
morbide.
Euh
le le la France médiatique d'après
guerre, elle s'est construite
notamment sur la foi d'un petit livre
absolument bouleversant
dont le titre était Les jours heureux.
C'était le programme du Conseil national
de la résistance. Alors, on en parle
beaucoup et on l'apprend à l'école parce
que c'est la sécurité sociale, tout ça.
Bon, ce qui est vrai, mais dans les
jours heureux, il y avait aussi des
passages sur la liberté de la presse
parce que la presse pendant la guerre a
sombré soit dans la collaboration
essentiellement, les journaux à s'être
s'abordés sont très rares en France.
Euh, il y a eu le progrès de Lyon par
exemple, le canard enchaîné et des et
d'autres he évidemment, mais c'est pas
comme les poissons volants, quoi.
C'était pas la majorité du genre. Soit
dans la corruption, soit dans les deux.
Bon, donc il a fallu reconstruire euh
l'idée de la presse indépendante et le
programme des jours heureux du CNR y a
participé et euh disait que il ne
fallait pas que derrière les médias euh
il y ait euh ce qu'on appelait, c'était
le l'expression à la mode à l'époque,
les puissances d'argent, hein. Et c'est
notamment là-dessus que Bry hein, le
fondateur du monde créera le monde en
disant qu'il ne voulait pas qu'il y ait
derrière le monde ni banque, ni État, ni
église. expression ni banque, ni état,
ni église. Euh et indéiablement le monde
créé au sortir de de la guerre a été un
un grand projet d'indépendance qui a
fait railler d'ailleurs tout de suite
avec le le le général de Gaulle et on se
rappelle des des batailles entre Cyrius,
Buie et et et De Gaulle.
Euh ce temps-là, ce temps de de ce
moment, cette époque, cette promesse de
l'indépendance de la presse et
aujourd'hui révolue. Voilà, il est
révolu.
Il y a pas besoin d'être très excité
pour constater que l'essentiel des
médias privés, c'est-à-dire en dehors du
service publicancé par la par la
redevance
appartiennent aujourd'hui dans sa très
grande majorité à des gens qui sont des
capitaines d'industrie qui sont
milliardaires et c'est très bien, j'ai
pas de problème, il y a pas de racisme
de l'argent mais dont le cœur d'activité
non seulement n'est pas l'information
mais et de
vendre des armes, faire du BTP, faire de
la téléphonie mobile, bollorer, c'est
faire
un peu tout ça et et bien plus
d'avoir des bonnes relations avec les
gouvernements en place successifs, qu'il
soit de droite ou de gauche, tout ça n'a
pas de couleur politique, voir avec des
dictatures étrangères. Bon euh par
exemple Boloré d'Assu euh en sont des
très bons exemples. Je veux dire une
dictature pour d'Asso, c'est c'est pas
une dictature, c'est un client potentiel
quoi. Bon Boloré, c'est c'est la même
chose notamment sur le continent euh sur
le continent africain.
Et donc il est pas besoin d'être hyper
vertébré politiquement ou très excité
pour constater que les intérêts
principaux de ces capitaines d'industrie
peuvent entrer en contradiction avec une
information libre et indépendante que
les journalistes qui travaillent dans
les titres qu'ils détiennent sont
susceptibles de produire. Bon et donc ça
c'est un énorme problème parce qu'ils
sont pas nombreux en fait hein. Ils sont
ils sont h ou neuf hein les gens dont je
parle d'assaut Boloré, Xavier Niel euh
euh François Pinot euh euh Bernard
Arnaud qui est quand même le leader
mondial du luxe et qui détient le seul
quotidien économique papier, les échos
et le le Parisien bon et quelques
autres. Et là
de fait on est dans un moment d'hyper
concentration des médias en France entre
les mains de quelques-uns. C'est la
définition de de l'oligarchie hein,
voilà
qui qui est évidemment un énorme
problème pour le foisonnement de
l'information libre et indépendante. Et
on voit bien ce que ça crée. Ça peut
créer de la censure, de la vraie
censure. Tiens, boloré à à censurer.
On l'avait raconté dans dans Mediapart,
c'est d'ailleurs Nicolas Vescovashi,
l'auteur du du documentaire qui est
celui qui a fait le cachestigation
sur la Libye, une enquête sur les
soupçons de fraude fiscale de système
d'organisation de fraude fiscale du
Crédit Mutuel qui devait être diffusé
sur Canal Plus. Il se trouve que Crédit
Mutuel,
voilà, c'était la banque Pach à
l'époque,
voilà, qui appartenait à à Crédit Mutuel
CIC, sauf qu'il trouve que c'est la
banque de monsieur Boloré. Et donc
Boloré d'un coup de fil à censurer le
sujet qui avait pourtant été validé par
par le service juridique et par la
direction des programmes de de Canal
Plus. Et non seulement il l'avait fait,
mais en plus il l'avait assumé ensuite
en comité d'entreprise devant les devant
les salariés en disant que c'était comme
ça et qu'on allait pas aller à
l'encontre des possibles annonceurs.
Enfin là, c'était plutôt un partenaire
financier. Bon, mais ça crée aussi la
pire des censures qui est l'autocensure.
C'est-à-dire quand tu travailles aux
échos, est-ce que c'est facile de faire
des enquêtes d'initiative sur les
paradis fiscaux quand tu sais que LVMH a
des sociétés dans les paradis fiscaux ?
On veux-tu ? Voilà. Bon, LVMH
propriétaire du journal. Je vais même
aller encore un peu plus loin. Si on va
dans le moteur de recherche des échos et
qu'on tape Nicolas Bazir Karashi. Bon,
l'affaire Karachi c'est une une histoire
de détournement d'argent sur les ventes
d'armes du gouvernement français sous
Édouard Baladur entre 93 et 95. Bien le
directeur de cabinet de Baladure à
l'époque c'était Nicolas Bazir. Nicolas
Bazir aujourd'hui c'est le numéro 2 de
LVMH, propriétaire des échos. Bon,
il fait quoi Jean-Louis Bruger en ce
moment ?
Jean-Louis Bruger ? Alors, je sais pas
ce qu'il fait. Il a fait beaucoup après
avoir été dans la justice
antiterroriste, il a beaucoup travaillé
dans le dans le dans le privé et il a
notamment travaillé pour Total dans
l'affaire AZF. Euh mais aujourd'hui, je
je sais pas, il a
l'affaire Carachi faisait quoi déjà ?
Alors, Brugerre, oui. Oui, Brugerre ça
avait été dans le volet terroriste de
l'affaire Karachie. C'était le juge qui
a voulu à tout prix et contre les
éléments qu'il avait dans son propre
dossier euh dire que l'attentat qui
avait visé des ingénieurs français à
Karashi en mai 2002 était le fait
d'Al-Qaïda. Voilà. Or, le dossier
montrait le le contraire. Tout laisse à
croire enfin à montrer à démontrer que
c'est les services de renseignement
pakistanais euh
voilà les redoutables Aessi qui sont
derrière cet attentat. Bon euh bon et
ben Nicolas Bazir qui est d'ailleurs
témoin de mariage he de Sarkozy et
Carlamoni
euh il est renvoyé devant le tribunal
correctionnel pour être jugé dans le
volet financier les détournements
d'argent sur les ventes d'armes de de
gouvernement Baladur. Bon et ben je sais
pas si ceux qui nous regardent peuvent
faire l'expérience. Je l'ai pas faite
depuis maintenant plusieurs années mais
si on tapait Bazir Karachi, on avait une
ou deux brèves qui remontaient. Bon bah
voilà. dans les échos, sur le site des
échos,
on fait comment pour vaincre cette
autocensure ? Et ben ça c'est on se bat
où on est mais c'est pas c'est vraiment
pas facile. Je il fait froid dehors.
Voilà. Et
les enfants ont besoin de manger.
Les enfants ont besoin de manger. Mais
il faut que la puissance publique
considère que lutter
pour la liberté d'informer c'est c'est
c'est pas tout à fait la liberté
d'expression. C'est la liberté
d'expression. C'est la liberté du
n'importe qui en démocratie de pouvoir
dire ce qu'il a envie de dire à
condition de ne pas mordre la ligne
jaune de l'incitation à la haine et
cetera et cetera. Bon, la liberté
d'informer, c'est un peu autre chose.
C'est la capacité
donner à des artisans du réel qui sont
les journalistes de pouvoir faire leur
travail
et d'assumer leur rôle de dérangeur, de
d'agent d'intranquillité. C'est notre
boulot.
Turbulent.
Ouais. C'est notre boulot.
L'intranquillité, c'est notre boulot. à
notre boulot, c'est de produire des
informations qui vont euh d'ailleurs,
c'est comme ça que le dit la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui est
la justice supranationale, la justice
européenne qui depuis 1976, donc c'est
quand même une vieille affaire tout ça,
a un arrêt qui est très beau qui
s'appelle l'arrêtide
euh qui dit que euh le journalisme et la
production d'information
peut en démocratie, je cite, heurter,
choqué, voire inquiété. Voilà, peut
heurter, choqué, voire inquiéter. C'est
quand même même pas rien. C'estàd que la
jurisprudence européenne qui nous
gouverne dit que le journalisme peut
heurter, choqué, voir inquiéter. Bah
oui, c'est notre rôle. Et
l'intranquillité, c'est ça. C'est ce qui
nous oblige à réfléchir sur nous-même,
qui nous oblige à pas être d'accord avec
nous-même, à heurter ses propres
convictions avec les informations. C'est
pas c'est pas les opinions qui qui qui
vous font réfléchir. Je crois pas. Moi
je pense qu'une opinion ça ça permet de
conforter avant même d'avoir lu ce
coup de parchoc qui te font réfléchir.
Oui, je pense que les je pense
sincèrement que ce sont les faits qui
font les opinions. Je ne crois pas que
les opinions font fassent les opinions.
C'est pour ça que moi j'aime bien ce
boulot là de de de producteur de réel
entre guillemets
de goûter les fêtes. Prendre en pleine
tête.
Ou mais bien sûr mais bien sûr bien sûr
qu'on se prend les faits. Voilà les
faits les faits ça amène à réfléchir.
Les faits sont producteurs de
conscience. les faits sont et ça et ça
heurte ça heurte ses aspirations, ça
peut heurter tes propres aspirations, ça
peut heurter tes propres convictions.
Bah c'est très bien comme ça, on n'est
pas toujours d'accord avec soi-même. Et
ben c'est je connais rien de mieux que
les faits pour pouvoir être pour pouvoir
produire produire produire ça.
Un avis sur France 24 et un avis sur RT
ou là
ou chatoué.
Ah oui
ouais. Alors, je je peux pas donner le
mec qui se défile, mais
je vois bien le parallélisme
en disant il y a deux il y a deux
les deux sont financés.
Ouais. Ouais. Les deux sont financés.
Euh
pour moi, la meilleure réponse, je vais
rester dans la droite ligne de ce que je
dis dep tout à l'heure, c'est de c'est
c'est de pas faire d'injonction de
principes contre les uns ou les autres.
Voilà, c'est ce sont des des télés liés
euh à des puissances publiques qui sont
des puissances politique. Voilà.
Euh je je pense
que le régime de Vladimir Poutine est un
régime autrement plus autoritaire que le
régime français et que Poutine est
autrement plus autoritaire que les
gouvernements
français.
Même après la SarkoZie, même après tout
ça.
Ouais. Je pense que
en dépit de son extrême faiblesse, la
démocratie française
est garante d'un certain nombre de
libertés plus que ce que je crois savoir
de loin de du régime
russe. Ouais, je le crois. Peut-être je
me trompe mais je le crois sincèrement.
Et donc pour répondre à la question,
il faut regarder ce qu'il produisent.
Voilà. Alors moi je connais pas assez
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai peur de
faire le normand et de me défiler. Il
faut regarder ce que Riou produit. Faut
analyser la ligne éditoriale, faut
analyser les faits qui qui rendent
publics. Est-ce que c'est vrai ? Est-ce
que c'est faux ? Tu as jamais mis les
doigts dans France 24 ni dans RT ?
Non. Alors moi c'est alors je je confess
truc que je fréquente très peu et France
24 et RT mais
[Musique]
dans certains pays les médias entre
guillemets d'état entre je met des
guillemets mais français sont vus comme
des instruments du pouvoir politique
français. Bien sûr on est toujours
l'étranger de quelqu'un, on est toujours
la puissance étrangère de quelqu'un. Et
euh je connais des Ivoiriens par exemple
euh qui considèrent que RFI a été la
voix de la France à à plusieurs égards,
pas que mais parfois au moment de la
chute de Bagbo. Voilà. et que parce que
il y a eu une conjonction des intérêts.
Je je dis pas qu'il a raison, qui a
tort, je dis que c'est un état de fait
qu'il y a des gens qui pensent ça et pas
et pas qu'un peu qui a eu une
conjonction des intérêts de de Nicolas
Sarkozy qui a confessé lui-même qu'il
avait mis Attara Alassan Attara au
pouvoir et fait tomber Bagbo. et
l'information autour de de Laurent
Bagbau à l'époque de sa chute il y a
quelques années en Côte d'Ivoire et que
les médias français, notamment les
médias qui sont sous la coupe du service
public français
n'ont pas toujours eu l'indépendance
qu'on attend d'eux. Voilà, c'est pas
toujours la BBC quoi. Voilà, qui est
plus indépendante du pouvoir
que parfois le le cordon ombilical. Je
reprends encore l'exemple de de Sarkozi.
on va croire que je suis obsédé, mais
euh euh qui se considérait comme
l'actionnaire, lui, comme l'actionnaire
de de du service public. Alors,
l'actionnaire du service public, en
fait, c'est le c'est le contribuable,
c'est celui qui paye la redevance, c'est
nous en fait les propriétaires du
service public, euh c'est pas le c'est
pas le c'est pas le ministère de tutelle
ou la présidence de la de la République.
Et donc là, il y a une grande grande
maladie française qui est celle de la de
la de la verticalité. Alors voilà et
donc s'il y a des fact checkers, on en
parlait tout à l'heure qui veulent
comparer
la production de Ruuda de Rioué et celle
de France 24 et voir ce qui est juste
qu'il faut. Voilà. Moi je
la liberté de la presse en France, on
est combiene ?
Ah bah d'après le classement de reporter
sans frontières,
on est on est on est économiquement la
5e puissance mondiale. On est le pays,
on dit souvent c'est le pays de la
déclar la pays des droits de l'homme.
C'est en fait c'est le pays de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme dans
la France. Euh ben on n'est pas 5e de ce
point de vue là. Voilà, je crois qu'on
est je sais pas entre 30 et 40. Je
connais pas le
ça va être 34.
Ouais 34 le classement par cœur. Donc
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment pas
glorieux. Euh avec mon confrère et ami
Paul Morera
qu'on passe le bonjour
qui qui codirige le le l'agence première
ligne qui produit Cach Investigation
entre autres. On avait on avait dirigé
un ouvrage avec 16 journalistes qui
avaient écrit dedans qui s'appelait
Informé n'est pas un délit. Et informé
n'est pas un délit était un un livre
dont le but était euh que plusieurs
journalistes dit d'enquête raconte une
enquête un peu symbolique pour eux qui
avait beaucoup fait couler d'encre et
fait parler d'elle et qui en même temps
la raconte à la première personne révèle
les embûes euh françaises face à la
liberté d'informer et ça allait du
harcèlement judiciaire d'un Denis Robert
dans la
Ouais les procédures Billon enfin Denis
Robert c'était c'était démon
passe le bonjour aussi
passe le bonjour c'était complètement
démence ce qu'il a eu à vivre. Il a eu
fait un très beau texte dans ce dans ce
livre face à face à Clerstream mais
aussi les violences physiques que ceux
qui enquêtent sur l'argent du Front
National et notamment par exemple
les paradis fiscaux aussi.
Ouais mais sur par exemple Marine Turchi
à Media Part qui qui enquête et qui
avait révélé le financement russe de du
Front National he qui est un un parti
qui est qui est pour la fermeture des
frontières et la souveraineté mais mais
pas celle de l'argent. Ça pas de
problème d'être le parti de l'étranger
de ce point de vue-là. Euh bon bah elle
Marine, elle se fait molester euh elle
s'est fait attaquer, elle s'est fait
physiquement, je veux dire. Bon voilà.
Mais on a racontter aussi euh le
contournement du droit de la presse. On
a raconté euh ce que c'est euh le
journalisme dans la presse locale.
Voilà. Comment les les baronies
politiques locales étouffent la liberté
d'informer d'un point de vue local qui
est une révolution majeure à mener en
France, hein. Il faut faut retourner la
table de l'information locale en France.
C'est terrible. Chaque grande ville n'a
qu'un quotidien qui est un peu au miroir
du potentat politique. Chaque grande
ville a son homme politique. C'est
généralement des hommes qui sont là
depuis des décennies bien installés. Et
puis il y a le journal, il y a un
journal, il y a pas de pluralisme très
peu, il y a pas de concurrence, il y a
pas d'émulation, il y a pas voilà et
puis il y a des financements publics de
la collectivité en question très
importante vers le journal. On est dans
un légitimisme de bonne allois et puis
bon benah il y a pas grand-chose qui
sort. Je veux pas du tout caricaturer et
généraliser surtout voilà. Mais venant
moi d'une grande ville à savoir Lyon, je
sais très bien comment ça se passe ces
choses-là et c'est effarant. Je veux
dire c'est mais on peut pas. Non
il mais je veux dire dans une grande
ville, une grande ville comme Lyon, une
grande ville comme Strasbourg, comme
Nant, comme je sais pas Marseille et AM
il devrait y avoir plusieurs quotidiens
qui se tirent la bour tous les jours qui
révèlent enfin je veux dire
il a pas d'argent.
Ouais il y a pas y a mais ouais mais il
y a pas d'argent. Tu gagnes
combien je gagne ? Moi je gagne 4 entre
4300 et 4400 € net par mois x 13. Voilà.
Plus donc ça c'est un médiia part euh
plus que je suis dans la la grille des
salaires. On a une grille des salaires
plus
euh euh un intéressement quand on fait
du bénéfice et on en fait euh et plus
combien d'intéressement ? Euh alors
alors là les chiffres je sais pas
ça doit être euh cette année ça doit
être je sais pas entre 1000 et 2000 €
mais ça c'est variable ça dépend voilà
et et puis aussi des contrats euh
d'édition que je peux avoir à côté quand
je fais des bouquins. Voilà. Moi j'ai
aucun problème à voilà.
Bah on voit ça.
Ouais ouais aucun su
les journalistes autrement euh burnés
comme toi
h
ils gagnent combien que dalle.
Non mais moi je fais partie des gens qui
sont
privilégiés
qui sont mais hyper bien payés dans la
profession. Je mets de côté la télé qui
est parfois quand même un je mets de
côté le le la télé le le le le le régime
de ceux qu'on voit à la télé parce que
dans la coulisse. Non mais c'est un
scandale. C'est un scandale. Non mais
c'est c'est une profession
des affemmes pour les rendre plus
dociles.
Je sais pas. En tout cas en tout cas la
précarité n'aide pas à l'indépendance.
Ça c'est sûr. Ça c'est certain. La
précarité, je l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
il fait froid dehors et ça la précarité
ça aide pas du tout. Ça aide pas du
tout. Bon et c'est une une profession
qui est dramatiquement
dramatiquement précarisé et on
m'interroge par exemple souvent sur
l'abattement fiscal des journalistes
hein parce que00
voilà les 7650 € qu'on retranche de la
du volume des revenus qu'on déclare qui
est pas c'est pas rien.
Avantages de la carte de presse aussi
pour acheter sa machine à laver. Alors
ça, moi j'ai jamais fait. J'ai Non.
Alors ça jamais. Non, mais même moi, moi
je suis un peu psychopathe là-dessus.
Euh
euh par exemple la carte de presse,
j'ai jamais grassé la pâte.
Non, mais par exemple, la carte de
presse, ça autorise à à rentrer
gratuitement dans les musées. Bah
heureusement.
Ouais. Mais alors ça, mais moi j'y
arrive pas. Je comprends pas pourquoi je
payeraai pas une place au musée,
sincèrement. Vraiment vraiment je
comprends pas ça. Euh mais par exemple,
l'abattement fiscal, il est mais
sincèrement alors je vais pas faire le
focus, je me l'applique, hein. Mon
épouse est journaliste, on se l'applique
tous les deux. est où ?
Elle travaille pour le site les jours un
super site. C'est des anciens de Libé
qui ont monté ça. Pe une sorte de de
journalisme en série quoi, de Netflix,
du journalisme. C'est hyper bien.
Lesjoujours.fr. Euh et
tu veux lui faire un bisou ?
Oui, bien sûr, toujours. Et euh et on
Mais mais ça n'a plus aucune
justification cet abattement. Cet
abattement n'a pas de n'a pas de
justification, je veux dire. Et et je
suis pour qu'on mette fin à cet
abatement. Je vois pas pourquoi nous
journalistes on aurait un abattement
fiscal au nom de quoi ? Bon, je veux
dire ça date de la
falloir augmenter les salaires alors
et voilà mais voilà je dire je je je je
suis pas non plus complètement con.
C'est-à-dire que OK OK on arrête
l'abattement en fiscale mais par contre
il faut augmenter les salaires et
augmenter les salaires de ceux qui qui
qui sont mal qui sont mal payés. Euh
donc, créons une caisse mutualiste avec
l'argent de l'abattement fiscal pour
verser. J'en sais rien. On peut imaginer
plein de trucs. Mais j'aurais rien
contre la fin de l'abattement fiscal des
journalistes. Au contraire, je inique.
Est-ce que tu vois un sujet à aborder
avec nous ? Est-ce que tu as envie de
parler d'un truc qui Non, on a envie de
parler d'un truc avec toi. Comment tu
fais pour te sécuriser euh pour faire
tes enquêtes
? Euh, on s'est permis un petit peu de
te scanner un peu avant que tu arrives.
Tu as un iPhone
h
tu as des applications poures dessus.
Bah comment ça ? J'ai euh
Tu as pas un Candy Crush ou une con ?
Ah non
non, tu as que Non non, j'ai signal
des choses comme ça.
Signal, j'ai Viber, j'ai télégram. Tu as
aucune application genre une lampe de
poche ?
Mais j'ai la lampe de poche de l'iPhone.
Ah ouais.
Et et tu en as d'autres applications que
tu as installé toi-même ? Genre tu as
pas une application pour jouer au poker
?
Non, j'ai un jeu de foot.
Tu as un jeu de foot ? D'accord.
Ouais.
Ton jeu de foot, il te demande quoi ? Il
a accès à ton micro, à tes contacts et
non. D'accord. Tu fais comment pour te
sécuriser en tant que journaliste ?
Alors, moi je suis très mauvais. Je suis
pas geek du tout. Voilà. Donc, mais euh
alors comment je fais ? On a un service
informatique au journal qui nous donne
un un nombre de prescriptions
importantes. Voilà.
Euh on a on a beaucoup travaillé avec la
quadrature du net.
On leur passe le bonjour.
On leur passe le bonjour à Mediapart
pour sécuriser un certain nombre de de
plateformes et cetera. Euh donc moi je
suis en alors j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
faille récemment mais je suis sur PGP.
J'ai voilà c'est crypté les mails.
C'est chiffré
c'est chiffré pardon. Ouais mais je suis
vraiment une brêle. Donc voilà, je suis
toutes les prescriptions du service
informatique.
Donc il nous arrive bah on a un
ordinateur non connecté.
Voilà,
on a par exemple un une plateforme qui
s'appelle French pour nous transmettre
des des documents de manière totalement
confidentielle. C'est c'est la
quadrature du Net qui nous a aidé à
faire tout ça.
Qui ça tu sais ? Non.
Benjamin
Bayard.
Non. Son de tag.
Ouais, son tag.
Voilà, Benjamin son tag qui nous a aidé.
Euh donc tout ça, ça se passe bah sur un
ordinateur qui n'est jamais connecté.
C'est c'est hyper compliqué des codes,
des lignes de codes pas possibles et
tout. Bon, moi j'apprends tout ça.
Voilà. Après, moi je fais bon après j'ai
les applications là signal tout ça.
Utilise beaucoup alors dans dans le
domaine dans lequel j'évolue
professionnellement
et notamment par exemple dans le monde
politique, tout le monde est persuadé
d'être écouté. Voilà, tout le monde est
sûr, vrai ou faux, mais tout le monde
est sûr qu'il est sur écoute. Les
députés, les ministres, ils ont sont
tous sûr qu'ils sont sur écoute tout le
temps. Voilà. Donc c'est vrai que c'est
hyper pratique ces trucs, ces signals ou
ces machins parce que une forme de
sentiment de sécurité numérique et donc
ils sont voilà. Bon euh alors moi je
suis très vieille école par ailleurs.
C'està-dire que je ne crois
qu'en qu'au rendez-vous physique.
Tu fais du d grade technologique.
C'est quoi du d grade technologique ?
Bah tu fais le téléphone arabe, tu
passes avec tes
Oui, je fais le téléphone arabe. Les
sources délicates ont on on
ont des surnoms pourris. Voilà.
Y compris dans ton téléphone portable.
Y compris dans mon téléphone portable.
C'est bien.
Voilà, ça arrive.
Tes collègues,
bah pareil, on essaie d'avoir une
culture commune quoi. Mais alors ça
c'est vraiment les gens de la technique
chez nous qui nous disent voilà qui
voilà fait h
voilà. Et alors on nous a dit aussi de
ne jamais trop en dire sur ce qu'on fait
et comment on le fait.
Comment tu te sécurises ?
Comment on sécurise ? Parce qu'on m'a
toujours donné l'exemple de Christophe
Barbier de l'Express qui un jour avait
dit dans ses éditaux là où il fait avec
sa son écharpe et à côté d'une plante
verte où il avait dit le site de
l'express est inviolable.
Ouais, il s'est fait défoncer dans la
demi-heure, c'est ça ? Ouais, c'est ça.
Dans la demi-heure, le site
lui a servi de leçon, hein, hein, ça lui
a fait du bien un peu.
Nous, on nous a voilà nous il y avait
une faille une fois il y a très
longtemps, il y a déjà de longues années
dans le dans le site, on l'avait rendu
publique la faille et qui était un il y
avait en effet une faille qui est qui
est qui est qui avait permis de rentrer
dans le dans le site à des hackurs. On n
jamais pu identifier
à des pirates. Ouais. Pas des hackurs,
pardon, des pirates.
Et euh on n jamais su d' d' d'où ça
venait. Mais ça nous a permis de
Vous faites un peu de pen test sur votre
infrastructure. Pen test
penetration testing.
Ah ben je pense je alors ça faut
vraiment demander au service mais je
pense ouais ils sont assez accrans quoi
dessus. Donc
vous conseillez Suyak ou Yogocha pour
vous je transmettrai. Voilà
on arrive à la fin de notre émission.
Euh tu vois un truc à aborder un sujet à
aborder ? Tuas envie d'aborder un truc
pour répondre. Non non ça va non super.
Donc la la l'avant-dernière question,
c'est pas une question, c'est laisser un
conseil pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer,
h
quelque chose d'impérissable sur les
réseaux.
Hm.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux laisser ?
Bah, c'est une question pour ceux qui
auraient envie de faire ce ce métier.
Enfin, pas une question, c'est une
bouteille dans lequelle je mettrai le
message de à l'adresse de ceux qui
auraient envie de faire ce ce boulot.
Euh
on me demande moi souvent c'est quoi les
qualités ? C'est quoi qu'il faut pour
être un bon journaliste. Bon et ce dont
je suis à peu près certain, c'est que ça
ne s'apprend pas à l'école, ça c'est
sûr. Euh et j'en vois en fait trois dont
la première
ça va paraître hyper tarte à la crème
mais je le crois vraiment
très cliché. très cliché mais c'est mais
je vais expliquer pourquoi c'est la
curiosité mais attention la curiosité
c'est une humilité vo en fait la
curiosité ça veut dire je sais pas moi
il y a rien qui me rend plus dingue que
les jeunes générations ou plus âgé peu
importe mais qui savent les gens qui
savent les sachant ils savent tout ils
savent ils savent comment faire l'équipe
de France et résoudre le conflit israël
aux palestiniens. Ils savent, voilà, ils
savent avant même d'apprendre. Voilà. Et
en fait, c'est quand même un truc de
malade notre boulot, c'est ne pas
savoir, apprendre et transmettre.
Tout ce que tout ce que tu sais, c'est
que tu ne sais rien.
Ouais. Non, mais vraiment alors c'est
pour ça que je dis c'est un peu mais
mais vraiment, je veux dire, on on
débarque dans un univers de savoir
immédiat. le journalisme, nous on
connaît pas, on découvre, on va au
contact de ceux qui savent des
documents, des sources et cetera, on
apprend, on vérifie et on transmet et on
transmet au plus grand nombre parce que
en fait ça nous appartient pas. C'est
justement ça le le on parle souvent de
la transparence. Voilà. Moi, c'est un
mot que j'aime pas du tout, la
transparence et d'ailleurs je pense
qu'il est utilisé, si ce n'est inventé
par ceux qui n'en veulent pas parce que
la transparence ça donne l'impression
qu'on veut voir au travers des gens. Ça
donne l'impression, il y a le mot
contient un peu une idée d'agression
intime. Et en fait, il y a un mot qui
était beaucoup plus beau qui était le
mot du débat des débats d'assemblée
pendant la révolution française. Ça
s'appelait la publicité.
Alors, depuis ça a été capté par la par
la valeur euh marchande. Mais c'est pour
ça par exemple qu'on dit la publicité
des débats pour pour la justice. La
publicité c'est un mot superbe parce
qu'il contient en lui-même sa promesse.
C'est ce qui appartient au public. Bah,
c'est ça notre boulot. C'est en fait
c'est comme un bien immatériel et ça
nous appartient pas. Ça appartient pas
au gouvern au gouvernant, ça appartient
pas aux entreprise. Ça ça appartient à
tout le monde. C'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça le droit des sociétés à
savoir. Grand textes internationaux
consacre ça. C'est-à-dire que euh
Victor Hugo qui a pas été que que poète
et écrivain, il a aussi été député. en
48, il avait une il avait eu une très
belle phrase à l'Assemblée. Il avait dit
que le droit de vote et la liberté
d'informer, c'est les deux facettes
d'une même pièce et que en démocratie,
si vous avez pas l'un et l'autre, en
fait, vous avez pas la démocratie. Si
vous avez le droit de vote sans la
liberté d'informer, sans la liberté de
savoir,
tu as des moutons.
Bah oui, tu votes avec un bandeau sur
les yeux. Donc voilà. Et si tu as la
liberté de savoir mais que tu peux pas
voter, tu es dans des dictatures
éclairées. Mais voilà. Bon euh et donc
c'est pas c'est pas rien comme comme
enjeu et c'est pour ça que je dis que la
curiosité c'est une humilité. Voilà. Bon
le deuxième c'est euh c'est c'est
la capacité d'indignation. Voilà je
déteste l'idée que euh les journalistes
seraient des comptables grisâtres du
réel. Je déteste l'idée de
l'objectivité. Je déteste l'idée de
l'objectivité parce que ça n'existe pas.
Je dire à partir du moment où tu décides
de travailler sur un sujet plutôt qu'un
autre, tu fais déjà un choix et le le
propre du subjectif, c'est le choix.
Bon, je crois à l'honnêteté, je crois à
l'inscérité, je crois au contradictoire,
je crois à tout ça. Je ne crois pas à à
l'objectivité et je suis désolé, euh
notre métier consiste aussi parfois à
avoir de l'empathie pour des situations.
Ça veut pas dire ne sombrer dans
l'émotion ou le sentimentalisme. Ça veut
pas dire être prisonnier de cela. Mais
on peut avoir des empathies, on peut
avoir des engagements. C'est-à-dire que
moi j'aime l'engagement, j'aime le
journalisme engagé, j'aime pas le le
journalisme militant, j'aime les idées,
j'aime pas l'idéologie dans la pratique
de mon métier.
Les journalistes qui sortent avec des
hommes politiques,
bah ça c'est compliqué hein.
Franchement, c'est compliqué. Je trouve
que c'est vraiment compliqué.
C'est c'est cette espèce de de de de
lien. Non, c'est hyper compliqué. Je
trouve que c'est c'est je les conflits
d'intérêt enfin les journalistes, ils
sont euh nous au journal, on a on a fait
là récemment pour nos 10 ans, tous les
journalistes ont publié leur déclaration
d'intérêt. On a fait des donc sur le
site de Media Part, il y a les
déclarations d'intérêt des gens.
Pourquoi une déclaration d'intérêt ? et
ben c'est de de de dire euh quels sont
qui tu couches.
Non, ça ça c'est ça c'est pas ça c'est
pas du tout euh il y a une liberté et un
secret euh intime euh de ça. Mais euh
non mais avec euh quelle est quelle est
la profession du compagnon ou de la
compagne ? Est-ce qu'on a euh
avec qui tu couches ? Ouais, mais ça
c'est plus que enfin c'est à qui on vit,
c'est à qui on partage euh voilà euh
avec euh
le Est-ce qu'on a des engagements en
dehors du de de notre journal dans un
parti euh politique, dans une
association, dans
dans une société secrète
qui peut dans une dans les ou les
francçons
ou ou alors les franc-maçons. Ouais.
Alors en l'occurrence
alors al question ça. Est-ce que ça
est-ce que ça rentre dans la déclaration
d'intérêt du journal ? Une bonne
question. Ça c'est une super bonne
question. Je sais pas. Ouais, ça je sais
pas. Est-ce qu'on a des actions ? Est-ce
qu'on a tout ce qui peut interférer avec
le domaine qu'on couvre dans le journal
? Voilà. Donc c'est c'est bien normal
qu'on qu'on ait cette transparent, cette
publicité cette publicité là. Et la
dernière chose euh dernier la dernière
qualité là c'est un truc pratique, bah
c'est euh
de jamais être résigné quoi, de de de
rien lâcher quoi. Voilà. parce que
jusqu'à la mort
bah en tout cas enfin jusqu'à
Qu'est-ce que tu es prêt à sacrifier ?
C'est-à-dire pour mon métier ?
Ouais.
Bah je sais pas, je
Bah beaucoup hein. J'ai je sacrifie
beaucoup pour mon pour mon métier. Mais
après il y a des choses.
Sacrifie quoi ?
Bah euh
ce qu'il y a de plus précieux
sur terre qui est le temps. Voilà.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un temps qu'on
consacre pas aux choses qui sont
essentielles dans nos vies.
Tes enfants.
Ouais. La famille, euh les voilà
l'amour. Voilà. Je crois j'ai une
hiérarchie personnelle. Voilà.
Normal.
Ouais. Je enfin je voilà
et et voilà. et et dans ce métier là,
c'est hyper facile de le faire avec une
flemme et une résignation et un
fatalisme. C'est hyper facile. Hyper
facile. Il y a une idéologie de la
communication qui est le pire ennemi du
journalisme. Le pire ennemi du
journalisme, c'est pas le mensonge,
c'est la communication
ou de manger dans la main de son maître.
Ah bah oui, bien sûr. Alors ah bah oui,
mais après c'est déjà bon, c'est plus du
journalisme, c'est de la publicité,
c'est de la réclame. Mais
voilà. Après,
il y a des il y a des gens comment dire,
je suis pas je suis vraiment pas pour
généraliser, c'est il y a des gens
indépendants partout. Voilà, il y a des
gens indépendants dans les au groupe la
garder à d'assao, chez Boloré. Il y a
des gens qui se battent, il y a des gens
voilà mais après c'est des problèmes
systémiques ça. On peut pas compter que
sur l'indépendance des individus. Voilà.
Et ça c'est un truc très français.
C'est-à-dire que les institutions
françaises, la 5e République et tout ça
ne compte que sur l'indépendance des
gens. Et moi, je pense que ce sont les
institutions qui doivent être
indépendantes et audacieuses. Pas
simplement le pari sur une personne une
fois qui est indépendante. Par exemple,
le procureur Molin dans l'affaire qui a
USAC, par exemple Intel, par exemple le
fonctionnaire qui tire la soline de
l'alarme et cetera à un moment donné euh
voilà, on n' pas un écosystème adulte et
mature de ce point de vue-là. C'est la
France est un pays qui est en panique
face au concept d'indépendance. C'est
celle des médias, c'est celle de
la justice, des contrepouvoirs et
et pourtant on nous a appris à l'école
avec Montesquieux que par la disposition
des choses, le pouvoir doit arrêter le
pouvoir et cetera. Bah en fait, on n pas
respecté la parole de l'un des pères de
la nation. Comme comme comment comme on
dit. Avant de terminer, je veux trois
bouquins.
Trois bouquins.
Euh alors, un bouquin de Michael
Boulgakov qui s'appelle Le maître et la
marguerite. Un bouquin qui avait été
interdit sur soviétique, absolument
euh magnifique comme la littérature
russe, fou, fantasque,
puissant,
profond, mélancolique. Voilà.
Euh alors là, c'est comme dans High
Fidelity là, faire des classements et
tout. Je suis euh si euh un bouquin euh
fabuleux d'un d'un d'un
journaliste que que j'adore,
l'un des paires du nouveau journalisme
comme qui s'appelle Getalise euh qui
était un des partenaires de Tom Wolf qui
qui vient de qui vient de mourir et qui
avait fait un livre où il avait pénétré
une famille mafieuse, une des cinq
familles de New York comme on disait
dans les années 70. Et le livre
s'appelle, il a un titre un peu bizarre
mais s'appelle "Ton père honorera,
honorera avec un S à la fin." Euh et il
raconte, enfin, c'est Scorcésien quoi,
il raconte de l'intérieur
la vie tranquille
d'une famille mafieuse à New York,
tranquille dans ses us et coutumes.
Voilà.
Euh et euh un 3è
un 3è livre euh
j'ai fait j'ai fait un roman, j'ai fait
euh Oh là là, c'est c'est terrible,
c'est terrible. Moi, c'est toujours
pareil quand on me demande quels sont
mes films préférés, mes disques
préférés.
Euh
bon, vas-y, ton disque préféré là. Ah
bah mon disque préféré
euh
moi j'ai enfin j'ai deux idoles, c'est
Miles Davis et le Kind of Blue de Miles
Davis parce que c'est c'est euh c'est
une une révolution au même titre que la
nouvelle vague a pété les codes du
cinéma académique ou que le nouveau
roman a détruit la narration académique.
Voilà, c'est quand même le gars qui a
réinventé le temps musical
et l'autre alors c'est pas un album,
c'est toute la discographie, c'est
l'ouride. Voilà parce que c'est la
rencontre de la littérature et du rock.
Fabrice, merci.
Merci.
Coupé.
[Musique]